हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल। तो प्लीज मुझे यह बताइए
सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है
क्या सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है
आई एम ऑडिबल एवरीवन
ओके वेरी गुड तो थोड़ा थोड़ा सा वेट करते
हैं बाकी स्टूडेंट्स के आने का फॉर
नेक्स्ट 1 मिनट।
तो सबसे पहले बताइए हाउ आर यू गाइस? आप सब
लोग कैसे हो?
प्रीवियस क्लास में जो भी कुछ मैंने
पढ़ाया था वो सबको क्लियर है। एनीवन हैव
एनी डाउट्स रिगार्डिंग टू द प्रीवियस
क्लास।
और सबको सब कुछ समझ में आ गया था।
प्लीज टेल मी एवरीवन।
एनीवन हैव एनी डाउट रिगार्डिंग टू द
प्रीवियस क्लास?
तो तो यह बताइए सबसे पहले कि कितने नए
स्टूडेंट्स हैं
जो आज फर्स्ट टाइम क्लास में आए
जगत गुरुजी कौन सी प्राइवेट क्लास आपकी
पेंडिंग है?
ओको इलेक्ट्रो वायरस यू आर फर्स्ट टाइम ऑन
लाइव
तो वेलकम टू डेफ्रोनिक्स
ओके यू हैव वाच रिकॉर्डेड सेशंस गुड चलिए
फिर एक काम करते हैं तो एक क्विक रिवीजन
करते हैं जो हमने प्रीवियस क्लास में पढ़ा
था ओके जो हमने प्रीवियस क्लास में पढ़ा
था उसका एक क्विक ओवरव्यू लेते हैं रिवीजन
करते हैं ताकि जो नए स्टूडेंट हैं जो
फर्स्ट टाइम आज क्लास ज्वाइन कर रहे हैं
इन द सेंस कि विदाउट एनी रिकॉर्डिंग जिसने
अभी तक रिकॉर्डिंग भी नहीं देखी है और
उसका जब फर्स्ट डे है आज कोर्स में तो
उनको भी पता चल जाएगा कि हमने प्रीवियस
क्लास में क्या चीज पढ़ी थी क्या चीज के
ऊपर डिस्कशन किया था ताकि आज की क्लास को
वो कोरिलेट कर पाए। तो लेट्स गो इनू आवर
स्लाइड्स। तो हमने टॉपिक स्टार्ट किया था
एक्सटर्नल पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग इनिशियल
एक्सेस का। तो हमने इंट्रोडक्शन किया था
कि एक्सटर्नल पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग क्या
चीज है? हम क्यों यूज करते हैं? और मैंने
आपको इंट्रोड्यूस किया था व्हाट इज
एक्सटर्नल पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग? तो अगर
आपको नहीं पता हो एक्सटर्नल पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग होता क्या है? तो मैं आपको बता
देता हूं। एक्सटर्नल पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग
का मतलब होता है किसी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के उन
सभी एसेट्स को टारगेट करना जो डायरेक्टली
इंटरनेट पर एक्सपोज्ड हैं। मतलब एक ऐसा
अटैकर जिसके पास कंपनी का कोई इंटरनल
एक्सेस या क्रेडेंशियल्स नहीं है। और वह
सिर्फ इंटरनेट पर बैठकर कहीं से भी कंपनी
के पैरामीटर्स को कैसे अटैक करेगा? यह
सिमुलेट करना ही क्या कहलाता है आपका?
एक्सटर्नल पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग। यह आपका
क्या कहलाता है? एक्सटर्नल पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग। व्हाट इज द मेन मेन गोल ऑफ
एक्सटर्नल पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग? एक्सटर्नल
पेन टेस्टिंग का मेन गोल होता है
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के जो आउटर पैरामीटर्स है।
ओके? जो ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के आउटर पैरामीटर
डिफेंस होता है उसको ब्रच करना और इंटरनल
नेटवर्क तक पहुंचना या इंटरनल नेटवर्क तक
पहुंचने का रास्ता ढूंढना ही मेन गोल होता
है आपका एक्सटर्नल पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग
का। यह सारी चीजें हमने डिस्कस की थी। तो
मेन गोल यहां पर हमने डिस्कस किया था। तो
आप प्रीवियस क्लास में देख लेना। मैं आपको
जो क्विक रिवीजन करवा देता हूं जो जो
मैंने हमने आपको बताया था। तो कुछ टाइप्स
होती है एक्सटर्नल पेट्रेशन टेस्टिंग की।
मैंने हाई ओवरव्यू दिया था कि एक्सटर्नल
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग के कौन-कौन सी टाइप्स
होती है। जैसे इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर नेवल
नेटवर्क लेवल टेस्टिंग होती है। वेब
एप्लीकेशन या एपीआई लेवल टेस्टिंग होती
है। सोशल इंजीनियरिंग या क्लाइंट साइड
टेस्टिंग होती है। क्लाउड इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर
लेवल टेस्टिंग होती है। सारी चीज क्या
होती है? आपकी टाइप्स ऑफ एक्सटर्नल
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग के अंदर आती हैं। और
जो मैंने आपको एक चीज भी बताई थी कि
इनिशियल एक्सेस क्यों मैटर करता है? किसी
भी कंपनी का इनिशियल एक्सेस क्यों मैटर
करता है? क्योंकि कोई भी एक हैकर, अटैकर,
पेंटेस्टर बाहर बैठकर जब इंटरनल नेटवर्क
के साथ या जो इंटरनल ऑर्गेनाइजेशन है या
जो एंप्लाइजज़ है जो या जो सिस्टम्स है
उनके अंदर क्या करता है? जो वो मूव करता
है, वह आपका क्या होता है? इनिशियल एक्सेस
होता है। और यह किसी भी पेंटेस्ट के लिए,
किसी भी अटैकर्स के लिए बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट
होता है इनिशियल एक्सेस लेना। विदाउट
इनिशियल एक्सेस नोबडी कैन डू एनीथिंग। तो
यह चीज हम ऑलरेडी
डिस्कस कर चुके हैं। तो मैं आपको जस्ट आगे
बढ़ रहा हूं। उसके बाद मैंने आपको एक चीज
बताई थी कि जो हमारा कोर्स जो चैप्टर है
वो ज्यादातर फोकस किस पे करने वाला? सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग और यूजर्स स्पेसिफिक सेंट्रिक
अटैक के ऊपर। क्यों? यह चीज भी मैंने आपको
एक्सप्लेन की थी कि सोशल इंजीनियरिंग और
क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स क्यों सबसे ज्यादा
प्रेफर किए जाते हैं। यह चीज भी हम
डिस्कस कर चुके हैं। यह टॉपिक ओवरव्यू है
जो अभी हम डिस्कस करने कंप्लीट करने वाले
हैं यहां पर। तो दीज़ आर द प्रीरिक्विजिट।
दिस इज योर लर्निंग ऑब्जेक्टिव दैट आई हैव
कवर्ड। तो, मैंने डिस्कस किया था क्लाइंट
साइड अटैक्स क्या होते हैं? यह भी मैंने
आपको बताया था। क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स उन
टेक्निक्स और टेिक्स को कहते हैं। जहां
अटैकर टारगेट ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस के यूजर्स या
एंप्लाइज
या यूजर्स या एंप्लई के सिस्टम और
सॉफ्टवेयर में मौजूद वनेबिलिटीज को या मिस
कॉन्फ़िगरेशनंस को एक्सप्लइट करते हैं। आई
होप ये चीज आपको पता होगा। ये डेफिनेशन
मैंने आपको बताया था। ऑब्जेक्टिव
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
क्या होता है? अटैकर्स का मेन ऑब्जेक्टिव
होता है एंड यूजर डिवाइसेस जैसे उनके
लैपटॉप्स या डेस्कटॉप्स या उनके
एप्लीकेशनेशंस या उनके बिहेवियर को
कॉम्प्रोमाइज करना।
कॉम्प्रोमाइज करना और टारगेट नेटवर्क के
अंदर इनिशियल एक्सेस लेना यह आपका उनका
मेन गोल होता है। किसके अंदर? क्लाइंट
साइड अटैक का मेन गोल होता है। तो ये चीज
मैं ऑलरेडी डिस्कस कर चुका हूं। तो इसमें
कुछ भी नई चीज नहीं है। आई आल्सो कंपेयर
विद सर्वर साइड एंड क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स।
यह भी मैं आपको आपके साथ कंपेयर कर चुका
हूं। तो, यह भी हमने डिस्कस किया था। और
मैंने एक चीज और बताई थी कि हम इसके अंदर
क्या सीखने वाले हैं कि जब किसी भी कंपनी
का जो पैरामीटर डिफेंस है जो आउटर नेटवर्क
है या जो उसके सर्वर्स है जो पूरी तरह से
सिक्यर्ड है या काफी सिक्यर्ड है तो उस
टाइम पर अगर हमें इंटरनल एक्सेस लेना है
या तो हम कैसे ले सकते हैं? उस समय हम
क्या करते हैं? किसी भी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के
सिक्योरिटी कंट्रोल्स के अंदर सबसे जो
वाइटल पार्ट होता है जो उनके एंप्लाइजज़
होते हैं उनको हम टारगेट करते हैं और उनसे
हम क्या करवाते हैं? उनको कन्विंस करते
हैं कि इस फिशिंग ईमेल पर क्लिक करो या
वेबसाइट पर क्लिक करो या उनसे हम
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करते हैं या उन्हीं से
ही उनके सिस्टम में एंट्री करवाते हैं। यह
एक तरीका होता है जिसको स्पेशली हम सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग के थ्रू ही करते हैं। दैट्स
दैट्स ऑल। ये हम कर चुके हैं। उसके बाद
मैंने कवर किया था कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट
डिपेंडेंसी कि जो क्लाइंट्स एंड अटैक्स
होते हैं वो डिपेंड करते हैं किसके ऊपर?
वो डिपेंड करते हैं कि टारगेट एनवायरमेंट
के ऊपर कि टारगेट एनवायरमेंट में कौन सा
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम यूज़ हो रहा है? कौन सा
ब्राउज़र इंस्टॉल है? ब्राउज़र का कौन सा
वर्जन है? Microsoft soft ऑफिस इंस्टॉल
है। इंस्टॉल नहीं है। क्या उसमें
माइक्रोज़ इनेबल है? नहीं है। एंड पॉइंट
प्रोटेक्शन एक्टिव है, नॉट एक्टिव है।
क्या वह जो टारगेटेड यूज़र्स है वह लोकल
एडमिन प्रिलजेस के साथ है या नहीं है? यह
सारी चीजें आपको पता होनी चाहिए। देन ओनली
यू कैन टारगेट
क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स या यू कैन परफॉर्म
सक्सेसफुल क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स। तो, यह
चीज हम डिस्कस कर चुके हैं ऑलरेडी। और
हमने जो लास्ट क्लास में जो बिल्कुल लास्ट
स्लाइड थी हमने पढ़ा था कैरेक्टरिस्टिक्स
ऑफ क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स। यह सारी चीजें
हमने पढ़ी थी कि क्लाइंट साइड अटैक की कुछ
कैरेक्टरिस्टिक सबसे पहले यूजर इंटरेक्शन
बहुत ज्यादा जरूरी है। उसके बाद क्लाइंट
साइड अटैक्स में कोई भी डायरेक्ट नेटवर्क
एक्सेस की कोई भी रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है।
और थर्ड वन हमने जो पढ़ा था ट्रस्टेड
डिलीवरी मैकेनिज्म। इसमें जो जो भी पेलोड
यूज़ किया जाता है या जो भी तरीका यूज किया
जाता है इस अटैक को परफॉर्म करने के लिए
उसका जो डिलीवरी मैकेनिज्म है कि अटैक
कैसे डिलीवर किया जाएगा वो काफी ट्रस्टेड
डिलीवरी मैकेनिज्म के थ्रू डिलीवर किया
जाता है। तो दैट्स ऑल। तो प्लीज मुझे यह
बताइए यहां तक हमने जो भी कुछ डिस्कस किया
था यहां तक सबको क्लियर है जो लास्ट क्लास
में हमने यहां तक जो भी कुछ डिस्कस किया
था यह था आपका क्विक ओवरव्यू हम बोल सकते
हैं क्विक रिवीजन किया था हमने कि लास्ट
क्लास में हमने क्या-क्या डिस्कस किया था
और आज का सेशन अभी हम स्टार्ट करेंगे तो
प्लीज टेल मी वंस अगेन एवरीथिंग इज क्लियर
एवरीवन प्लीज एवरीवन आई रिक्वेस्ट एवरीवन
प्लीज आंसर
ओके प्लीज देयर ओनली टू स्टूडेंट्स बाकी
चलिए
नाउ लेट्स स्टार्ट आवर टॉपिक तो आज हम बात
करने वाले हैं एडवांटेजेस ऑफ क्लाइंट साइड
अटैक्स। एडवांटेजेस ऑफ क्लाइंट साइड
अटैक्स। तो अब सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट एक सवाल
उठता है कि हमारे पास इतने बड़े-बड़े
सर्वर्स हैं। फिर भी अटैकर्स क्लाइंट साइड
अटैक्स को क्यों प्रेफर करते हैं? या
क्यों इतना चाहते हैं कि मैं क्लाइंट साइड
अटैक्स ही परफॉर्म करूं। या व्हाई अटैकर्स
लव क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स? तो इसके चार कुछ
इसके पीछे कुछ चार बड़े रीजंस हैं। क्लाइंट
साइड अटैक परफॉर्म करने के कुछ चार बड़े
रीजंस हैं। सबसे पहले है लार्जर एंड वाइड
अटैक सरफेस। लार्जर एंड वाइड अटैक सरफेस।
एंड यूज़र्स सच एज डेस्कटॉप, डेस्कटॉप
कंप्यूटरटर्स, लैपटॉप, स्मार्टफोनस,
टैबलेट्स आर यूबी क्यूटीएस इन मॉडर्न
ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस प्रोवाइडिंग ए लार्ज अटैक
सरफेस ऑफ फॉर एक्सप्लइटेशन।
मॉडर्न ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस में हर एक एंप्लई
के पास लैपटॉप, डेस्कटॉप, स्मार्टफोन और
टेबलेट है। अब जितने भी ज्यादा डिवाइसेस
उतना बड़ा अटैक सरफेस। अब किसी
ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस के लिए अपने सारे सर्वर्स
को सिक्योर रखना
आसान है। या सारे सारे जो सर्वर्स है उनको
सिक्योर रखना बहुत आसान हो सकता है। पर उस
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के 500, 1000, 2000, 3000 या
100 एंप्लाइज को कंटीन्यूसली
ट्रेन करना या उनके सारे डिवाइसेस को
सिक्योर रखना नेक्स्ट टू इंपॉसिबल होता
है। नेक्स्ट टू इंपॉसिबल होता है। मतलब
इतना आसान नहीं है कि उसके सारे के सारे
एंप्लई को आप क्या कर पाओ? ट्रेन कर पाओ।
यह सबसे चैलेंजिंग और सबसे मोस्ट डिफिकल्ट
टास्क होता है किसी भी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के
लिए। तो सेकंड बड़ा रीजन कौन सा होता है?
यूजर इंटरेक्शन मतलब एक्सप्लइटिंग ह्यूमन
नेचर। क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स लेवरेज ह्यूमन
वेलनेबिलिटीज सच एज कसिटी ट्रस्ट
इग्नोरेंस टू ट्रिक यूजर्स इनू
एग्जीक्यूटिंग मिलेशियस कोड और डिविलिगिंग
सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन
यह अटैक्स क्या करता है कि टेक्निकल
वनेबिलिटी से ज्यादा ह्यूमन वेलनेबिलिटीज
पर काम करता है। कैसे? क्योंकि किसी भी
इंसान की फितरत होती है क्रियोसिटी,
उत्सुकता,
ट्रस्ट, भरोसा या इग्नोरेंस मतलब
अनअवेयरनेस। और अटैकर क्या करता है? इसी
का फायदा उठाकर उन्हें मैनपुलेट करता है
और उनसे मशियस कोड रन करवा लेता है। दैट
इज़ सेकंड बिग रीजन। थर्ड वन आता है आपका
लेस स्ट्रेंथ सिक्योरिटी कंट्रोल्स। मतलब
एंड यूजर डिवाइसेस मे हैव लेस रोबट
सिक्योरिटी मेजर्स कंपेयर टू सर्वर्स और
नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर मेकिंग देम मोर
ससेप्टेबल टू एक्सप्लइटेशन।
इसका मतलब क्या है कि जो भी एंड यूजर
डिवाइसेस हैं उनके ऊपर जो सिक्योरिटी
मेजर्स होते हैं वह थोड़े लाइट होते हैं
कंपेयर टू द सर्वर्स। फॉर एग्जांपल एक एम
जब एक एंप्लई जब तक ऑफिस में है वह कंपनी
के फायर वाल और मॉनिटरिंग के अंदर है।
लेकिन जब वही यूज़र्स कंपनी के लैपटॉप को
घर लेकर जाता है और घर लेकर जाता है और
वहां पर काम करता है तो क्या होता है?
वहां से उनके नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक को उस लेवल
पर मॉनिटरिंग करना इंपॉसिबल है जो आप एक
कंपनी के अंदर रहकर मॉनिटरिंग और
या सिक्योरिटी कंट्रोल्स लगा सकते हो।
इसलिए उस समय क्या होता है? उन टारगेट
उन्हें टारगेट करना बहुत आसान होता है। आई
आई थिंक यू अंडरस्टैंड कि मतलब यह है कि
जब तक वह एंप्लई ऑफिस में है तब तक आप
उसके जो भी डिवाइसेस है या जो भी कंपनी ने
उसको जो भी लैपटॉप या जो भी
ऐसा डिवाइस प्रोवाइड किया है ऐसा एसेट
प्रोवाइड किया है जो वो साथ में कैरी करता
है घर पे भी वो सिक्योर है क्योंकि वो
कंपनी के फायर वाल्स या ईडीएस या ईडीएस या
सोर या एंड पॉइंट डिटेक्शंस की रेंज में
है। अब जब वह एंप्लॉय उस डिवाइस को वहां
से लेके जाने के बाद इंटरनेट पे यूज़ करता
है तो तो इनसिक्योर ही है क्योंकि कंपनी
उस लेवल पर उसको मॉनिटर नहीं कर सकती जिस
लेवल पर कंपनी के अंदर कर सकते हैं। इसलिए
यह भी एक सबसे बड़ा रीजन है क्लाइंट साइड
अटैक्स का। फोर्थ वन क्या है? पोटेंशियल
फॉर लेटरल मूवमेंट। वंस इनिशियल एक्सेस इज
अचीव्ड थ्रू ए क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स
अटैकर्स मे पीवोट टू अदर सिस्टम्स और
रिसोर्सेज विद इन द नेटवर्क टू एस्केलेट
प्रिविलेजेस अचीव पर्सिस्टेंस और
एक्सफिल्ट्रेट डाटा मतलब
जो फोर्थ रीजन है सबसे बड़ा एडवांटेज है
क्योंकि एक बार जब आपको क्लाइंट साइड अटैक
के जरिए किसी एक एंप्लई के सिस्टम पर
इनिशियल एक्सेस मिल जाता है तो क्या होता
है आपका सारा का सारा काम आसान हो जाता
है। कैसे? उसके बाद हमारी जो स्टैंडर्ड
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग मेथोडोलॉजी होती है
या जो स्टैंडर्ड पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग जो
अप्रोच होती है वो शुरू हो जाती है। हम
क्या कर सकते हैं? उस कॉम्प्रोमाइज सिस्टम
से लैटरल मूवमेंट और पिवेटिंग परफॉर्म
करते हैं और ताकि हम ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के बाकी
क्रिटिकल सर्वर्स और डेटाबेस तक पहुंच
सके। पहुंच सके और उन्हें डोमेन कंट्रोलर
को कंप्रोमाइज कर सकें या उनके सिस्टम्स
को कंप्रोमाइज कर सकें। आई मीन कि हम क्या
कर सकते हैं कि जो बाकी दूसरे भी डिवाइसेस
हैं उनको हम क्या कर सकते हैं उनके उनको
कॉम्प्रोमाइज करने की कोशिश करते हैं विद
दी हेल्प ऑफ आपके लेटरल मूवमेंट पीवोट या
आप प्रिविलज एस्केलेशन कर सकते हैं। मतलब
आप क्या कर सकते हो? जब आपको इनिशियल
एक्सेस मिल गया विद दी हेल्प ऑफ ए क्लाइंट
साइड अटैक्स आप क्या कर सकते हो आपकी जो
भी पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग की जो ओल्ड मेथोड
जो ओल्ड अप्रोच होती हैं उनको क्या कर
सकते हो आप यूज़ कर सकते हो आई होप यहां तक
सबको क्लियर होगा
दैट इज दैट इज योर हाई लेवल ओवरव्यू ऑफ कि
क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स क्या होते हैं और
उनका स्कोप क्या है मेरा समझ में आ गया कि
आपके जो क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स है या जो
इतने बड़े-बड़े सर्वर्स होने के बावजूद भी
कोई भी अटैकर्स क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स को
क्यों चुनता है? क्योंकि उसके चार बड़े
रीज़ंस हैं। सबसे बड़ा रीज़ंस क्या है? कि जो
भी एंड यूज़र्स हैं, जो भी एंप्लाइजज़ हैं,
उनके पास डेस्कटॉप है, स्मार्टफोनस है,
टैबलेट्स हैं। मतलब उनके पास एक उनका अटैक
सरफेस बहुत ज्यादा बड़ा है। और जहां पर
अटैक सरफेस बड़ा होगा, वहां पर क्या होगा?
आपका जो हैकर्स है, वो डेफिनेटली होगा। और
दूसरा दूसरा रीज़न क्या है? दूसरा रीज़न
क्या है? कि एंप्लाइजज़ को सारे के सारे
एम्प्लाइज को ट्रेन करना इतना आसान नहीं
है। थर्ड हमने बात की थी यूजर इंटरेक्शन
की मतलब कि जो क्लेंस अटैक्स है उसमें
ह्यूमन वनेबिलिटीज को एक्सप्लइट किया जाता
है ना कि आपकी टेक्निकल वनेबिलिटीज। अब जो
इंसान हैं जो एम्प्लाइज हैं उनमें कमियां
होती हैं। क्यूरियोसिटी भी होती है। वह
जल्दी से किसी पर ट्रस्ट भी कर लेते हैं
या फिर इग्नोर उनको अनअवेयरनेस अनअवेयर
हैं। मतलब सिक्योरिटी
सिस्टम से या उनको इतनी नॉलेज नहीं है या
उनकी इतनी ट्रेनिंग नहीं हुई है। मतलब वो
चीजों से अनअवेयर हैं। वो भी एक मेजर रीजन
है क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स का। उसके बाद आ
गया कि जो एंड यूजर डिवाइसेस हैं उनके ऊपर
जो सिक्योरिटी कंट्रोल्स हैं वो कम होते
हैं। खासकर कब? जब वो उन डिवाइसेस को अपने
घर से ऑपरेट करते हैं। उसके बाद लेटरल
मूवमेंट। एक बार आपको इनिशियल एक्सेस मिल
गया उसके बाद तो लेटरल मूवमेंट हो ही सकता
है। वहां से लेटरल मूवमेंट या पीवेट आप कर
ही सकते हैं। बिकॉज़ आप उस इंटर नेटवर्क के
अंदर।
आई होप यहां तक सबको क्लियर हो गया होगा।
नेक्स्ट
क्लाइंट साइड वर्सेस सर्वर साइड अटैक्स।
अभी तक हमने दो तरह के अटैक्स को अटैक्स
का एक ब्रीफ ओवरव्यू लिया है। कौन सा
अटैक्स? एक तो क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स और
सर्वर साइड अटैक्स।
लेकिन रियल वर्ल्ड एग्जीक्यूशन के लिए
आपको इन दोनों के बीच का एक एग्जैक्ट
क्लियर डिफरेंस पता होना चाहिए। जब तक
आपको इनका एग्जैक्ट क्लियर डिफरेंस नहीं
पता होगा तब तक आप इन दोनों में
डिफरेंशिएट नहीं कर पाओगे। इन दोनों के
बीच हमेशा कंफ्यूज रहोगे कि सर्वर साइड
अटैक्स कौन से होते हैं? क्लाइंट साइड
अटैक्स कौन से होते हैं? तो चलिए हम क्या
करते हैं? इनको चार मेजर पैराटर्स पर
कंपेयर करते हैं। जिन वो कौन-कौन से चार
मेजर पैराटर्स? टारगेट, ऑब्जेक्टिव,
एग्ज़क्यूशन एंड एग्जांपल्स। तो, लेट्स अह
फ़ ऑफ़ ऑल स्टार्ट विद द टारगेट। हम बात
करते हैं कि क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स में
टारगेट
क्या होते हैं? कौन होते हैं? टारगेट एंड
डिवाइसेस एंड यूजर डिवाइसेस एप्लीकेशनेशंस
और बिहेवियर्स। दीज़ अटैक्स एक्सप्लइट
वनेबिलिटीज इन सॉफ्टवेयर और सिस्टम
एक्सेस्ड बाय यूज़र्स सच एज वेब ब्राउज़र्स,
ईमेल क्लाइंट्स और ऑफिस एप्लीकेशनेशंस।
अगर हम क्लाइंट सेट अटैक्स की बात करें तो
उसमें टारगेट कौन कौन होगा? आपके एंड यूजर
डिवाइसेस जैसे आपके लैपटॉप, डेस्कटॉप,
मोबाइल्स और उनमें चलने वाली
एप्लीकेशनेशंस जैसे वेब ब्राउज़र्स हो
गया, ईमेल क्लाइंट हो गया, Microsoft
Office हो गया, पीडीएफ रीडर्स हो गया या
अदर्स ऐसे सॉफ्टवेयर जो है ज्यादातर यूज़
किए जाते हैं। तो दीज़ आर द टारगेट्स ऑफ
क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स। अब बात करते हैं इन
कंपैरिजन टू सर्वर साइड अटैक्स कि सर्वर
साइड अटैक्स में टारगेट क्या होगा आपका?
तो टारगेट सर्वर्स नेटवर्क
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर और बैक एंड सिस्टम्स दी
अटैक फोकस ऑन एक्सप्लइटिंग वनबिलिटीज इन
सर्वर्स डेटाबेसिस वेब एप्लीकेशनेशंस और
सर्विज होस्टेड ऑन रिमोट सर्वर्स। अभी
सर्वर साइड अटैक्स के अंदर जो आपके टारगेट
होंगे वो होंगे आपके इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर
सर्वर हो गए। आपके बैक एंड सिस्टम्स हो गए
या आपके जो कंपनीज के जो डेटाबसेस होंगे,
डेटाबेस सर्वर्स होंगे या जो रिमोट
होस्टेड वेब एप्लीकेशनेशंस वो सारे के
सारे आपके क्या होंगे? टारगेट हो गए इन
सर्वर साइड अटैक्स। नाउ कम्स टू आवर सेकंड
पैरामीटर दैट इज ऑब्जेक्टिव। अब क्लाइंट
साइड अटैक्स का ऑब्जेक्टिव जानते हैं कि
मेन ऑब्जेक्टिव क्या होता है? एम टू
कंप्रोमाइज एंड यूजर डिवाइसेस स्टिल
सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन एस्टैब्लिश ए
फुटहोल्ड विद इन एन ऑर्गेनाइजेशन नेटवर्क।
दीज़ अटैक्स ऑफन लेवरेज सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
टैिक्स और टू ट्रिक यूज़र्स इनू परफॉर्मिंग
एक्शंस दैट फैसिलिटेट द अटैक्स।
अब ऑब्जेक्टिव की बात करें तो क्लाइंट
साइड अटैक्स उनका ऑब्जेक्टिव होता है एंड
यूजर डिवाइसेस को कॉम्प्रोमाइज करना, यूजर
बिहेवियर का फायदा उठाना, क्रेडेंशियल
स्टील करना और नेटवर्क में इनिशियल फुट
होल्ड बनाना। यह होता है आपका क्लाइंट
साइड अटैक्स का ऑब्जेक्टिव। नाउ कम्स टू
आवर सर्वर साइड अटैक्स। एम टू गेन अन
ऑथराइज एक्सेस टू सर्वर्स और बैक एंड
सिस्टम्स एक्स फिल्ट्रेट सेंसिटिव डाटा और
डिप्ट डिसरप्ट सर्विसेज दीज़ अटैक्स मे
एक्सप्लइट वनेबिलिटीज इन सर्वर सॉफ्टवेयर
मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस और इनसिक्योर सर्वर साइज
स्क्रिप्टिंग मतलब अभी इसका मतलब यह है कि
सर्वर साइड अटैक्स का ऑब्जेक्टिव होता है
सर्वर्स का अनऑथराइज्ड एक्सेस लेना।
डाटाबेस से बल्क अमाउंट ऑफ डाटा
एक्सिल्ट्रेट मतलब चोरी करना या सर्वर्स
को डाउन या डिसरप्ट करना या डिडोर्स अटैक
करना ताकि उसकी सर्विज डाउन हो जाए। दैट
इज द मेन ऑब्जेक्टिव ऑफ ए सर्वर साइड
अटैक्स। नाउ टेल मी यू हैव द क्लियर दीज़
टू कंपैरिजन।
नेक्स्ट
अब बात करते हैं एग्जीक्यूशन इन टर्म्स ऑफ
क्लाइंट से अटैक्स।
इट टिपिकली इनवॉल्व द डिलीवरी ऑफ मिलसियस
कंटेंट और पेलोड्स टू एंड यूजर डिवाइसेस
थ्रू चैनल सच एज फिशिंग ईमेल्स, मिलसियस
वेबसाइट्स और इनफेक्टेड डॉक्यूमेंट्स।
मतलब एग्जीक्यूशन की बात करें तो इसमें
क्या होता है? क्लाइंट अटैक्स में यूजर
इंटरेक्शन बहुत ज्यादा जरूरी होता है। आप
इसमें क्या करते हैं? हैं जो मिलिशियस
पेलोड होते हैं उनको आप फेसिंग ईमेल्स या
इनफेक्टेड डॉक्यूमेंट्स या अनट्रस्टेड
वेबसाइट्स के जरिए यूजर तक डिलीवर करते
हैं और यूजर को कन्विंस करते हैं कि वह
उनके ऊपर क्लिक करें उन फाइल्स को डाउनलोड
करें और जब वो यूजर उन फाइल को डाउनलोड या
उस लिंक पे क्लिक करता है तो जो आपका वो
मिलिशियस फाइल है वह एग्जीक्यूट होती है
देन ओनली आपको इनिशियल एक्सेस मिलता है
दैट इज द एग्जीक्यूशन फेस इन कंपैरिजन टू
क्लाइंट एंड अटैक्स नाउ कम्स टू आवर सर्वर
साइड अटैक्स उसका एग्जीक्यूशन क्या होता
है? एक्सप्लइट वनेबिलिटीज और वीकनेसेस इन
सर्वर साइड सॉफ्टवेयर सर्विज और
कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस। अब इसमें क्या होता है?
सर्वर साइड अटैक्स में इसमें आप क्या करते
हो? डायरेक्ट इंटरनल सिस्टम के अंदर
वनेबिलिटीज को टारगेट करते हो। हो सकता है
कि सर्वर के ऊपर कोई ऐसा अनपैच सॉफ्टवेयर
चल रहा हो या उस पर्टिकुलर वर्जन के अंदर
या पर्टिकुलर सर्वर के अंदर मिस
कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस है। आप क्या करते हैं उनका?
उस पर्टिकुलर अनपैच सॉफ्टवेयर या मिस
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन को लेवरेज करते हैं और
बिना किसी यूजर इंटरेक्शन के उनको अटैक
करते हैं। दैट इज द एग्जीक्यूशन फज़ ऑफ़
सर्वर साइड अटैक्स। एग्जांपल की बात करें।
एग्जांपल होते हैं क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स के
फिशिंग, सोशल इंजीनियरिंग, ड्राइव बाय
डाउनलोड्स, मिलसियस,
मैक अटैचमेंट्स या आप ब्राउज़र एक्सप्लइट
कि ये इसके एग्जांपल हैं आपके क्लाइंट
साइड अटैक्स के। अब बात कर रहे हैं सर्वर
साइड अटैक्स में आते हैं आपके एसक्यूएल
इंजेक्शन क्रॉस साइज स्क्रिप्टिंग
एसएसआरएफ आरसीई या सर्वर मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस
ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक एटसेट्रा इज द पार्ट ऑफ
द सर्वर साइड अटैक्स। ये जस्ट एक
एग्जांपल्स हैं। तो आई होप कि लेट इज़ द
कंपैरिजन ऑफ क्लाइंट साइड एंड सर्वर साइड
अटैक्स। और सबको क्लियर हो गया होगा
क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स और सर्वर साइड अटैक्स
में क्या डिफरेंस है।
सबको क्लियर है?
चलो अभी आते हैं नेक्स्ट टॉपिक पर हाउ
क्लाइंट साइड अटैक वर्क्स।
देखो अभी तक हमने अपना जो थ्योरी पार्ट था
उसको क्या कर लिया? समझ लिया? लेकिन
सवाल यह है कि रियल लाइफ में एक क्लाइंट
साइड अटैक स्टेप बाय स्टेप कैसे परफॉर्म
होता है? या एक अटैकर या एक हैकर या रेड
टीमर जीरो से शुरू करके इंटरनल नेटवर्क तक
कैसे पहुंचता है? आई होप यह सबका सवाल
होगा। सबके दिमाग में सवाल होगा कि एक
क्लाइंट सेट अटैक को स्टेप बाय स्टेप कैसे
परफॉर्म किया जाता है या कोई भी हैकर कोई
भी अटैकर्स या कोई भी पेंटेस्टर
या कोई भी रेड टीमर जीरो से शुरू करता है
और इंटरनल नेटवर्क तक कैसे पहुंचता है?
जीरो से इंटरनल नेटवर्क तक वह कैसे
पहुंचता है? तो इसको समझने के लिए हम क्या
करने वाले हैं? अभी एक छोटा सा सिनेरियो
लेने वाले हैं। एक छोटा सा एग्जांपल लेने
वाले हैं या छोटा सा एक एक इमेजिनेटिव
कंपनी का एग्जांपल लेंगे और उसकी हेल्प से
हम समझेंगे कि यह कैसे पॉसिबल है
प्रैक्टिकली भी। नाउ हाउ क्लाइंट साइड
अटैक वर्क्स। लेट अस कंसीडर ए फिक्टियस
एग्जांपल ऑफ ए क्लाइंट साइड अटैक
टारगेटिंग एन ऑर्गेनाइजेशन कॉल्ड एसीजी
कॉरपोरेशन। मतलब इसको समझने के लिए हम
क्या करने वाले हैं? अभी एक इमेजिनेटिव
कंपनी का एग्जांपल लेते हैं या इसको समझने
के लिए पहले हम एक ऐसा एग्जांपल लेते हैं
जिसमें कंपनी का नाम है एसीजी कॉरपोरेशन
प्राइवेट लिमिटेड। इन दिस फिकटियस कम
एग्जांपल द क्लाइंट साइड अटैक बिगिंस विद
रिकॉन एंड टारगेट आइडेंटिफिकेशन फॉललोड
बाय पेलोड डेवलपमेंट डिलीवरी एंड
एग्जीक्यूशन। इसमें क्या होता है? इस
एग्जांपल में जो क्लाइंट साइड अटैक है वो
रिकॉर्न और टारगेट आइडेंटिफिकेशन से
स्टार्ट होता है। उसके बाद फॉललोड बाय
पेलोड डेवलपमेंट डिलीवरी एंड एग्जीक्यूशन
एंड द अटैकर लेवरेज सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
टैिक्स एंड एक्सप्लइट वनेबिलिटीज इन
क्लाइंट साइड सॉफ्टवेयर टू गेन अन
ऑथराइज्ड एक्सेस टू एसीजी कॉरपोरेशन
नेटवर्क एंड अल्टीमेटली अचीविंग देयर
मिलसियस ऑब्जेक्टिव। मतलब क्या होता है?
जो अटैकर्स है वो अटैकर्स सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग टेक्निक का यूज़ करता है। उसके
बाद जो क्लाइंट साइड सॉफ्टवेयर है उसके
अंदर प्रेजेंट वनेबिलिटीज को एक्सप्लइट
करता है।
उसके अंदर प्रेजेंट वनेरेबिलिटीज प्रेजेंट
वनेबिलिटीज को एक्सप्लइट करके जो एसीजी
कॉरपोरेशन का इंटरनल नेटवर्क है जो ए जो
एसीजी कॉरपोरेशन प्राइवेट लिमिटेड कंपनी
का जो नेटवर्क है उसके अंदर अन ऑथराइज
एक्सेस गेन करता है टी टू अचीव देयर
मिलिशियस ऑब्जेक्टिव। तो यह है पूरी कहानी
जिसके ऊपर हम अभी काम करने वाले हैं कि
इमेजिन करिए कि आपकी जो एसीजी कॉरपोरेशन
प्राइवेट लिमिटेड कंपनी है उसके जो फायर
वाल्स हैं और उसका जो नेटवर्क सर्स है वह
बिल्कुल अप टू डेट और पेस्ट है। अब एज एन
अटैकर्स हमने क्या किया? हमने चूज़ किया कि
हम इंटरनल एक्सेस के लिए क्लाइंट साइड
मेथोडोलॉजी का यूज करेंगे। क्लाइंट साइड
अटैक्स को परफॉर्म करेंगे टू अचीव आवर
ऑब्जेक्टिव। ऑब्जेक्टिव हमारा क्या है?
इंटरनल नेटवर्क के अंदर एक्सेस लेना।
जिसमें हम क्या करने वाले हैं? जिसमें हम
टोटल सेवन स्टेप्स यूज़ करेंगे। जिसमें हम
क्या करने वाले हैं? टोटल सेवन स्टेप्स
करने वाले हैं। तो सबसे पहला स्टेप आपका
रिकॉन। सबसे पहला स्टेप क्या है आपका?
रिकॉन। द अटैकर बिगिंस बाय कंडक्टिंग
रिकॉर्न ऑन एसजी कॉरपोरेशन यूजिंग
पब्लिकली अवेलेबल इंफॉर्मेशन। सोशल मीडिया
प्रोफाइल्स, कंपनी वेबसाइट्स एंड जॉब
पोस्टिंग। अटैकर सबसे पहले क्या करता है?
अटैकर सबसे पहले एसीजी कॉरपोरेशन के बारे
में पब्लिकली अवेलेबल इंफॉर्मेशन गैदर
करता है। जैसे उसकी Lindin प्रोफाइल के
बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करता है।
कंपनी वेबसाइट के बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदर करता है। उसके टेक्नोलॉजी स्टक के
बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करता है।
उसकी सोशल मीडिया इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करता
है। और या कोई जॉब पोस्टिंग है या कोई भी
जॉब जॉब ओपनिंग पोस्ट है उनके बारे में
क्या करता है? इंफॉर्मेशन कलेक्ट करता है।
उसके बाद क्या होता है? द अटैकर
आइडेंटिफाई एंप्लाइज देयर रोल्स एंड
पोटेंशियल टारगेट वििन द ऑर्गेनाइजेशन। अब
जो यह इंफॉर्मेशन है जो भी इंफॉर्मेशन या
अटैकर कलेक्ट कर रहा है ड्यूरिंग देयर
रिकॉर्न फेज ड्यूरिंग देयर इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग फेज उसका मेन गोल क्या है? कंपनी
के एंप्लाइजज़ और उनके रोल्स को आइडेंटिफाई
करना। क्यों? क्योंकि उसके लिए उसको क्या
करना है? टारगेट सिलेक्शन करना है। टारगेट
सिलेक्शन में क्या है कि अटैकर ऐसे
डिपार्टमेंट्स को टारगेट करना चाहता है जो
एक्सटर्नल फाइल से सबसे ज्यादा डील करते
हैं। और किसी भी कंपनी में एक्सटर्नल फाइल
से सबसे ज्यादा डील करने वाले कौन से
एंप्लई होते हैं? या तो उनका एचआर
डिपार्टमेंट्स होता है या फाइनेंस
डिपार्टमेंट होता है या फिर मार्केटिंग
डिपार्टमेंट्स होता है। यह तीन
डिपार्टमेंट्स होते हैं। किसी भी कंपनी
में सबसे ज्यादा क्या करते हैं? वह
एक्सटर्नल फाइल के साथ डील करते हैं। तो
यह चीज सिलेक्शन के लिए क्या करता है? वह
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करता है। दूसरा उसके
लिए उसके अलावा अटैकर और क्या-क्या अटैकर
और क्या-क्या रिकॉर्न करता है? द अटैकर
गैदर इंफॉर्मेशन अबाउट एसीजी कॉरपोरेशन
टेक्नोलॉजी स्टक, ईमेल डोमेनस एंड कॉमन
सॉफ्टवेयर एप्लीकेशन यूज्ड बाय द
एंप्लाइजज़। और इसके अलावा अटैकर क्या करता
है? कंपनी के अंदर यूज होने वाले
टेक्नोलॉजी स्टक के बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन
कलेक्ट करता है। ईमेल डोमेनस के बारे में
इंफॉर्मेशन क्रैक करता है या कॉमन
सॉफ्टवेयर एप्लीकेशनेशंस के बारे में पता
लगाता है और उनको क्या करता है? अपने एक
लिस्ट के अंदर या अपने डॉक्यूमेंट के अंदर
उनको नोट डाउन करता है जो फ्यूचर में उसके
अटैक के काम आने वाले हैं। नेक्स्ट स्टेप
कौन सा होता है? स्टेप टू। स्टेप टू में
क्या होता है? टारगेट आइडेंटिफिकेशन
बेस्ड ऑन रिकॉन फाइंडिंग द अटैकर
आइडेंटिफाई स्पेसिफिक इंडिविजुअल्स विद इन
एसीजी कॉरपोरेशन हु आर लाइकली टू हैव
एक्सेस टू सेंसिटिव इनेशन और वैल्यूुएबल
एसेट्स
द अटैकर सेलेक्ट्स पोटेंशियल टारगेट फॉर
क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स सच एज एंप्लॉय इन
फाइनेंस ह्यूमन रिसोर्सेज और एग्जीक्यूटिव
पोजीशंस अब इस स्टेप में क्या होता है कि
जो भी इंफॉर्मेशन आपको इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
स्टेप में मिली है। उस इंफॉर्मेशन या उस
डाटा के बेसिस पर अटैकर किसी स्पेसिफिक
इंडिविजुअल को फिल्टर आउट करता है। खासकर
उन लोगों को जिनके पास सेंसिटिव इंटरनल
एक्सेस हो सकता है। फॉर एग्जांपल फाइनेंस
मैनेजर या आपका एचआर एग्जीक्यूटिव को
ज्यादातर किसी भी कंपनी के जो फाइनेंस
मैनेजर होते हैं या जो किसी भी एचआर
एग्जीक्यूटिव उनको ज्यादातर मेन टारगेट के
रूप में सेलेक्ट किया जाता है। किसी भी
अटैकर के द्वारा, किसी भी कंपनी के
अगेंस्ट, किसी भी टारगेट सिलेक्शन प्रोसेस
में। ओके? नाउ स्टेप थ्री होता है आपका।
स्टेप थ्री में आता है आपका पेलोड एंड
रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट। पेलोड एंड रिसोर्स
डेवलपमेंट। द अटैकर डेवलप्स ए मशियस
डॉक्यूमेंट कंटेनिंग ए पेलोड सच एज
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड डॉक्यूमेंट विद एन
एंबेडेड मैक और ए पीडीएफ फाइल विद ए
जावास्क्रिप्ट एक्सप्लइट।
अब
रिकॉन कर लिया। रिकॉन में आपने टारगेट
आइडेंटिफाई कर लिया। आपने टारगेट सेलेक्ट
कर लिया। दो स्टेप में। तीसरा स्टेप क्या
आता है? अब आपका थर्ड स्टेप आता है हथियार
रेडी करना। मतलब एक मिलिशियस डॉक्यूमेंट
डेवलप करना। मतलब पेलोड या रिसोर्स
डेवलपमेंट। आपको अभी क्या करना है? अपना
हथियार रेडी करना है अगेंस्ट द टारगेट। उस
टारगेट के खिलाफ। मतलब फॉर एग्जांपल एक
ऐसा माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड डॉक्यूमेंट जिसमें
क्या हो मैक एंबेडेड हो मिलेशियस मै
एंबेडेड हो या एक ऐसी पीडीएफ फाइल जिसके
अंदर जावास्क्रिप्ट का एक्सप्लइट कोड हो
जिसके अंदर जावास्क्रिप्ट का एक्सप्लइट
कोड हो दी पेलोड इट डिज़ टू एक्सप्लइट
वनेबिलिटीज इन कॉमन सॉफ्टवेयर एप्लीकेशन
यूज्ड बाय एसीजी कॉरपोरेशन सच एज
Microsoft Office और AOब रीडर्स अब
जो यह पेलोड है इस पेड को इस तरह डिजाइन
किया जाता है जो एसीजी कॉरपोरेशन में
स्टैंडर्ड सॉफ्टवेयर रन कर रहे हैं। जैसे
आपका माइक्रोफ्ट ऑफिस हो गया या एडoब रीडर
होगा वो उनके एग्जीक्यूशन मैकेनिज्म को
अब्यूज कर सके। मतलब यह है कि जो आप पेलोड
या जो भी रिसोर्स आप डेवलप करोगे उसको इस
तरह डिजाइन करना है कि जो आपका टारगेट
कंपनी है या जो टारगेट ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस है
उसके अंदर जो स्टैंडर्ड सॉफ्टवेयर रन कर
रहे हैं उनका जो एग्जीक्यूशन फेस है उसको
अब्यूज कर सकें। अब वह कैसे पॉसिबल है?
पॉसिबल है। वह तभी पॉसिबल है जब आपके पास
क्या होगी? उस स्टैंडर्ड सॉफ्टवेयर की
इंफॉर्मेशन होगी। वह इंफॉर्मेशन कहां से
आएगी? आपको स्टेप वन से आएगी। वो
इंफॉर्मेशन आपको कहां से आएगी? आपको स्टेप
वन से आएगी। वो इंफॉर्मेशन।
हेलो गाइज़ सबको मेरी आवाज आ रही है ना?
सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है ना? लाउड
एंड क्लियर?
प्लीज बताइए।
ओके। तो सबको समझ में आ रहा है? जैसे मैं
समझाने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं।
सबको समझ में आ रहा है?
ओके।
नेक्स्ट स्टेप फोर होता है आपका पेलोड
प्रिपरेशन। द अटैकर क्रिएट्स ए कन्विंसिंग
प्री टेक्स्ट फॉर पेलोड डिलीवरी सच एज
क्राफ्टिंग ए फिशिंग ईमेल मास्क रीडिंग एज
एनेंट डॉक्यूमेंट फ्रॉम ए ट्रस्टेड सोर्स।
फ्रॉम ए ट्रस्टेड सोर्स। अब ये टैकर क्या
करता है कि अब आपका पेलोड रेडी है। आपका
पेलोड रेडी है स्टेप थ्री से। लेकिन
उसको यूजर से क्या करवाना? रन करवाना है।
इसके लिए अटैकर क्या करता है? एक ऐसी
स्टोरी एक ऐसी फेक स्टोरी तैयार करता है
जिससे आपका जो यूजर है वो कन्वेंस हो जाए,
इन्फ्लुएंस हो जाए या यूजर स्टोरी को मान
ले। यूजर स्टोरी को मान ले। और उसके लिए
क्या करता है? द अटैक सेट अप
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर टू होर्स द मिलेशियस
डॉक्यूमेंट और पेलोड सच एज कॉम्प्रोमाइज
वेबसाइट और ए टेंपरेरी फाइल शेयरिंग
सर्विस। मतलब जैसे कि एक फेसिंग ईमेल
जो ऐसा लगे कि किसी ट्रस्टेड वेंडर या
मैनेजमेंट की तरफ से आया है। मतलब कि पेड
प्रिपरेशन में यूजर से आप यूजर को कन्विंस
करना है। यूजर को एक स्टोरी चिपकानी है।
स्टोरी चिपकाने के लिए हम क्या करेंगे?
फॉर एग्जांपल हम एक फिशिंग ईमेल भेज रहे
हैं। तो वो ईमेल ऐसी होनी चाहिए कि यूजर
को लगे या किसी ट्रस्टेड वेंडर से आई है
जिसके साथ कंपनी डील करती है या उन्हीं के
मैनेजमेंट की तरफ से वो ईमेल आई है।
उन्हीं के मैनेजमेंट की तरफ से ईमेल आई है
और और
उस ईमेल को और भी ज्यादा नॉन सस्िशियस
बनाने के लिए या और भी ज्यादा उसको
ट्रस्टेड या उसको
बोल सकते हैं कि
प्रिटेक्स्ट करने के लिए हम क्या करने
वाले हैं? हम उसको होस्ट कर देंगे। मतलब
एक टेंपरेरी फाइल सर्विस के ऊपर उसको एक
टेंपरेरी फाइल सर्विस के ऊपर या एक
कॉम्प्रोमाइज डोमेन है उसके ऊपर सेटअप कर
देंगे ताकि सस्पिशियस ना लगे ताकि
सस्िशियस ना लगे इसलिए यहां यह आपका स्टेप
फोर स्टेप फोर में आपने क्या किया पेलोड
आपके पास है जब पेलोड आ गया तो उस पेलोड
को क्या करना है आपको उसके अगेंस्ट एक
स्टोरी रेडी करनी है एक फेसिंग ईमेल रेडी
करनी है और उसके लिए जो जो तैयारी करनी है
जैसे उसके लिए आपको डोमेन चाहिए तो डोमेन
आप यूज़ करोगे उसके उसके लिए कोई सर्विस
सेटअप करनी है, सर्विस सेटअप करोगे। मतलब
एक स्टोरी बना रहे हो और वो स्टोरी सामने
वाले को पसंद आनी चाहिए। बेसिकली सिंपल
एंड सरल भाषा में यह है कि वो स्टोरी आपकी
सामने वाले को पसंद आनी चाहिए। उनको
ट्रस्टेड लगनी चाहिए और आपकी स्टोरी में
जितनी सच्चाई होगी उतना जल्दी चांसेस हैं
कि वो उस पे क्लिक करें।
ओके? तो नेक्स्ट स्टेप आता है आपका स्टेप
फाइव में होता है आपका पेलोड डिलीवरी।
स्टेप फाइव होता है आपका पेलोड डिलीवरी। द
अटैकर सेंड फेसिंग ईमेल टू सिलेक्टेड
एम्प्लाइज विद इन एसीजी कॉरपोरेशन अर्जिंग
देम टू रिव्यू द अटैच डॉक्यूमेंट और क्लिक
ऑन ए लिंक टू एक्सेसेंट इंफॉर्मेशन
द फिशिंग ईमेल मे कंटेन सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
टैक्टिक टू इंक्रीस द लाइकलीहुड ऑफ सक्सेस
सच एज अर्जेंसी फियर और क्यूरियोसिटी। अब
इस स्टेप में क्या होता है कि अटैकर
सिलेक्टेड एंप्लाइज को एक कस्टमाइज फेसिंग
ईमेल भेज देता है। स्टेप फाइव में क्या
होता है कि स्टेप फाइव में अटैकर जितने भी
सिलेक्टेड एंप्लाइजज़ होते हैं टारगेट
टारगेट जो भी टारगेट किए गए हैं सबको वो
कस्टमाइज फेसिंग ईमेल सेंड कर देता है और
उस ईमेल में क्या करता है? उस ईमेल में
अर्जेंसी या तो कोई अर्जेंसी वाला मैसेज
होगा या कोई फियर जिसमें मतलब कि एंप्लई
को डर लगे कि या कुछ क्यूरियोसिटी
उत्सुकता जैसी साइकोलॉजी ट्रिक का यूज
करेगा। मतलब मैं आपको पढ़ाऊंगा जब सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग का टॉपिक स्टार्ट करेंगे ना
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग में आपको बताऊंगा कि
जो साइकोलॉजी होती है ना वो कैसे ट्रिगर
होती है? कितने टाइप की साइकोलॉजी यूज
होती है सोशल इंजीनियरिंग में। में वह
सारी चीज हम डिस्कस करने वाले हैं काफी
डीप में। तो काफी इंटरेस्टिंग बनाऊंगा
आपकी सोशल इंजीनियरिंग क्लास को भी। तो
इसलिए क्या करता है कि कोई भी अटैकर जब उस
कस्टमाइज फिशिंग ईमेल को भेजता है ना तो
उसमें क्या करता है? तीन चीजें यूज़ करता
है। या तो अर्जेंसी यूज़ करेगा या फियर यूज़
करेगा या कयोसिटी यूज़ करेगा। मतलब ये कुछ
साइकोलॉजिकल ट्रिक होती है जिनका यूज़ किया
जाता है। फॉर एग्जांपल जैसे उसने यूज़ किया
अर्जेंट प्लीज रिव्यू द अटैच्ड सैलरी
रिवीजन स्ट्रक्चर इमीडिएटली। अभी
अर्जेंट ही है यह कि प्लीज सैलरी से
रिलेटेड बात है तो अभी आप ही बताइए आपके
पास ऐसी कोई ईमेल आएगी तुरंत उस पे आप
ब्लाइंडली आप क्या कर दो क्लिक कर दोगे तो
ये सारी चीजें आपके स्टेप बाय स्टेप होती
है तो नेक्स्ट स्टेप आता है आपका पेलोड
एग्जीक्यूशन नेक्स्ट स्टेप आता है आपका
पेलोड एग्जीक्यूशन ए टारगेटेड एंप्लॉय एट
एसीजी कॉरपोरेशन रिसीव द फीसिंग ईमेल एंड
ओपन द मिलिशियस डॉक्यूमेंट और क्लिक द
प्रोवाइडेड लिंक मतलब यह है की अब एसीजी
कॉरपोरेशन का जो भी एक टारगेटेड एंप्लॉय
था उस ईमेल को ओपन करता है और क्यूसिटी
में आकर उस अटैचमेंट पर डबल क्लिक कर देता
है या लिंक पर क्लिक करता है और जैसे ही
वह क्लिक करता है जैसे ही उस डॉक्यूमेंट
को ओपन करता है उसके अंदर प्रेजेंट जो मैक
कोड था वह एग्जीक्यूट होता है और
सॉफ्टवेयर के कंट्रोल को बाय बायपास कर
देता है और जैसे उसको बाईपास करेगा तो
क्या करेगा सिस्टम बैकग्राउंड में अटैकर
को पेलोड जो अटैकर जो पेलोड उसको रन कर
देता है। मींस द एंबेडेड पेलोड एग्जीक्यूट
एक्सप्लइटिंग वनेबिलिटी इन द क्लाइंट साइड
सॉफ्टवेयर टू गेन ए फुटहोल्ड ऑन द
एंप्लाइजस डिवाइस। मतलब यह है कि जैसे
डॉक्यूमेंट पर क्लिक किया उसके अंदर जो
कोड था वो एग्जीक्यूट होगा और बैकग्राउंड
में जो पेलोड था वह रन करने लग जाएगा। एंड
द अटैकर्स पेलोड एस्टैब्लिश कम्युनिकेशन
विद ए कमांड एंड कंट्रोल सर्वर कंट्रोल
बाय द अटैकर इनेबलिंग फर्दर इंटरेक्शन एंड
कंट्रोल और यह पेलोड क्या करेगा तुरंत
इंटरनेट के जरिए अटैकर के कमांड एंड
कंट्रोल सर्वर को एक रिवर्स कनेक्शन भेज
देगा और जैसे ही रिवर्स कनेक्शन गया तो जो
अटैकर है अटैकर को टारगेट डिवाइस का रिमोट
एक्सेस मिल जाएगा। जो अटैकर है उसको
टारगेट डिवाइस का रिमोट एक्सेस मिल जाएगा।
नेक्स्ट
स्टेप कौन सा है? पोस्ट एक्सप्लइटेशन
विद एक्सेस टू द एम्प्लाइज डिवाइस द अटैकर
मे परफॉर्म पोस्ट एक्सप्लइटेशन एक्टिविटीज
सच एज प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन, लेटरल मूवमेंट
और डाटा एक्सकल्टेशन। द अटैकर मे एस्केलेट
प्रिविलजेस टू गेन हायर लेवल एक्सेस विद
इन एसीजी कॉरपोरेशन नेटवर्क मूविंग लेटरली
टू कंप्रोमाइज एडिशनल सिस्टम्स और
रिसोर्सेज।
मतलब क्या होता है? जब अटैकर अटैकर क्या
है? अटैकर टारगेट नेटवर्क के अंदर एंटर कर
चुका है। अब यहां से क्या करता है वह उसकी
जो भी पुरानी जो टेक्निक्स हैं उनको यूज़
करता है या जो हम जो भी पेन टेस्टिंग
टेक्निक्स का यूज़ करते हैं जैसे प्रिलिज
एस्केलेशन, लेटरल मूवमेंट, डेटा
एक्सप्लेशन वो सारी चीजें परफॉर्म कर करता
है स्टेप सेवन में। मींस दीज़ आर द क्लाइंट
साइड अटैक मेथोडोलजी। मेथोडोलॉजी मतलब
सबसे पहले रिकॉन उसके बाद टारगेट
आइडेंटिफिकेशन उसके बाद टारगेट आइडेंटिफाई
हो गया टारगेट सिलेक्शन हो गया देन उसके
बाद क्या रिसोर्स डेवलपमेंट होता है पेलोड
डेवलपमेंट उसके बाद पेलोड प्रिपेयर किया
जाता है उसके बाद पेलोड को डिलीवर किया
जाता है। फिर पेलोड को एग्जीक्यूट करवाया
जाता है। उसके बाद आप पोस्ट एक्सप्लइटेशन
फज़ स्टार्ट होता है। वहां पर आपका नॉर्मल
पेन टेस्टिंग वाले स्टेप परफॉर्म होते
हैं। तो यहां तक सबको क्लियर है कि
क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स स्टेप बाय स्टेप कैसे
परफॉर्म होता है। मैंने आपको एक कंपनी का
एक एक मतलब एक एग्जांपल लिया है। एक
सिनेरियो लिया है। उस सिनेरियो में स्टेप
बाय स्टेप कैसे चीजें परफॉर्म हुई वो शायद
आपको क्लियर हो गई होंगी। या किसी को समझ
में नहीं आया तो प्लीज मुझसे पूछिए।
इलेक्ट्रो वायर्स पूछ रहे हैं कि सर
क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स आर नॉट परमिटेड इन बग
बंटी बिकॉज़ क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स परमिटेड
नहीं है। उसका एक कारण है क्योंकि जब भी
आप किसी भी
पेन टेस्टिंग में क्लाइंट साइड अटैक
परफॉर्म करोगे तो उसके लिए आपके पास एक
ऑथराइजेशन ऑथराइजेशन होना चाहिए। आपके पास
रूल ऑफ इंगेजमेंट लिखा होना चाहिए कि
कंपनी आपसे क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स या सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग अटैक्स भी परफॉर्म करवाना
चाहती है। अगर आपके पास रिटर्न अप्रूवल
नहीं है, रिटर्न अथॉरिटी नहीं है तो प्लीज
डू नॉट परफॉर्म क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स बिकॉज़
इट इज इललीगल।
तो मुझे एक चीज बताइए
जितने स्टूडेंट हैं व्हाट इज द डिफरेंस
बिटवीन बग बाउंट एंड पेन टेस्टिंग?
व्हाट इज द डिफरेंस बिटवीन पेन टेस्टिंग
एंड बग बाउंटी? क्या बग बाउंट और पेन
टेस्टिंग में कोई डिफरेंस है?
अगर है तो क्या
जल्दी से बताइए
क्या बग बाउंट है टेक्स्ट में
या एग्जैक्टली
क्योंकि बग बाउंटी एक स्कोप लिमिटेड है और
पेन टेस्टिंग का स्कोप लिमिटेड नहीं होता।
पेन टेस्टिंग में आपको बहुत सारी चीजें
आनी चाहिए। बहुत सारी चीजें कवर होनी
चाहिए। इसलिए मेरा सजेशन हमेशा यह होता है
कि
बग बाउंट अच्छी बात है। फ्री टाइम में बट
हर किसी को पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर बनना चाहिए।
ऑफेंसिव पेंटेस्टर, ऑफेंसिव रेड टीमर
क्योंकि उसका कोई भी स्कोप लिमिटेड नहीं
होता। उसमें आपको बहुत कुछ सीखने को मिलता
है। मतलब इतना कुछ दो आप ओनली बग बाउंट
में नहीं सीख सकते। बग में आप वेब से
रिलेटेड ही चीजें सीखते हो। लेकिन पेन
टेस्टिंग बहुत ज्यादा एक्साइटेड होती है
क्योंकि उसमें सच में क्योंकि जॉब उसी के
बेस पर होती है एक तो ज्यादातर तो उस जॉब
में काफी इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें आपको करने को
मिलती है बहुत कुछ सीखने को मिलता है
दैट्स व्हाई पेन टेस्टिंग इज पेन टेस्टिंग
जरूर सीखनी चाहिए क्योंकि पेन टेस्टिंग
में आप वो हर चीज करते हो आप वो हर टूल
टूल हर वो इंफॉर्मेशन लेते हो वो काफी
इंटरेस्ट एक्साइटेड डोमेन होता है तो आई
होप सबको समझ में आया होगा कि मैं आपको
क्या बताने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं
हम क्या करते हैं? हम सब बग बाउंट से
लिमिटेड हो जाते हैं कि बस उतना ही सब कुछ
है। इसके आगे कुछ भी नहीं है। बस ऐसा नहीं
है। और दिस इज अ स्मॉल पार्ट।
ओके
एवरीवन सबको पता है चीज।
चलिए फिर टॉपिक पर चलते हैं अपने पे।
क्लास में सबको समझ में आ रहा है?
सबको समझ में आ रहा है कि व्हाट इज गोइंग
ऑन? क्या चल रहा है? क्या नहीं चल रहा?
ओके। नेक्स्ट है क्लाइंट साइड अटैक
वेक्टर्स।
क्लाइंट साइड अटैक वेक्टर्स। चलो एक चीज
है। आगे बढ़ने से पहले
यह सिनेरियो अभी याद है आपको? अभी-अभी
जस्ट मैंने आपके सामने एक सिनेरियो कवर
किया है। यह सिनेरियो सबको पता समझ में आ
गया?
यह सिनेरियो सबको समझ में आ गया?
छोटा सा आपको एक यहां से मैं एक सीख सीखने
वाली बात बताता हूं। देखो
आपने पूरा सिनेरियो समझ लिया। इस पूरे
सिनेरियो में अगर आपने एक बात नोटिस की
होगी कि अटैकर ने एसीजी कॉरपोरेशन के किसी
भी फायर वाल को हैक नहीं किया। उन्होंने
क्या किया? सिर्फ सिस्टम की सॉफ्टवेयर
कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस और एंप्लई के बिहेवियर का
फायदा उठाया। समझ में आया? उसने ना तो
किसी फायर वाल को हैक किया ना किसी सर्वर
को हैक किया। उसने क्या किया? ओनली जो
सिस्टम कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस है या जो एंप्लई है
कंपनी का जो क्लाइंट है या जो कंपनी का जो
एंप्लॉय है उसका जो बिहेवियर था या उसकी
जो मेंटालिटी थी या उसकी जो साइकोलॉजी थी
सब उसी का फायदा उठाया। और इसी वजह से
कहते हैं कि जो क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स होते
हैं वह इतने ज्यादा सोफिस्टिकेटेड और
डेंजरस माने जाते हैं जाते हैं कि जो
सर्वर साइड अटैक्स हैं वो उसके सामने कुछ
भी नहीं होते। क्योंकि कभी भी देखना कि
ज्यादातर जितने भी रैंसमवेयर अटैक्स रहे
होंगे ज्यादातर जितने भी बिग डाटा अटैक्स
हुए रहे होंगे उनमें कहीं ना कहीं क्लाइंट
साइड अटैक्स का इन्वॉल्वमेंट होता ही होता
है। विदाउट क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स मे बी कोई
भी बड़ा अटैक्स परफॉर्म नहीं हो सकता।
बिकॉज़ क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स होता है ना वो
बहुत एक्यूरेट इंफॉर्मेशन देता है कंपेयर
टू द सर्वर साइड और बाकी अदर अटैक्स। दैट
इज व्हाई जो आपका क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स है
वो आपका क्या है? काफी सोफस्टिकेटेड और
डेंजरस अटैक्स में से एक अटैक माना जाता
है और जो आप सीख रहे हो। कहीं मिसयूज़ मत
करना वरना सीधा जेल में जाओगे। तो नाउ अभी
डीप ड्राइव चलते हैं क्लाइंट साइड अटैक
पैक के अंदर। देखो अब तक हमने क्या किया
जो क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स थे उनका एक हाई
लेवल ओवरव्यू ले लिया है। हमें पता चल गया
कि क्लाइंट साइड अटैक होता क्या है? उसके
स्कोप क्या है? अभी हम क्या करते हैं?
थोड़ा डीप ड्राइव करते हैं और हम उन
स्पेसिफिक अटैक वेक्टर्स और टेक्नोलॉजी को
समझ समझेंगे जो अटैकर्स और पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टर्स इनिशियल एक्सेस के लिए यूज करते
हैं। और सबसे पहले एक बेसिक कांसेप्ट
क्लियर करते हैं हम कि अटैक वेक्टर्स क्या
होता है? व्हाट आर अटैक वेक्टर्स? मतलब
क्लाइंट सेट अटैक पढ़ अह वेक्टर पढ़ने से
पहले हमें यह पता होना चाहिए कि अटैक
वेक्टर होता क्या है? इन द कॉन्टेक्स्ट ऑफ
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग एन अटैक वेक्टर्स
रेफर्ड टू ए पाथ और ए मेथड यूज्ड बाय एन
अटैकर टू एक्सप्लइट वनेबिलिटीज और
वीकनेसेस इन ए सिस्टम नेटवर्क और
एप्लीकेशन।
कंटेस्टिंग के कॉन्टेक्स्ट में अटैक
वेक्टर्स उन उस पाथ या मेथड्स को कहते हैं
जिसका यूज करके एक अटैकर किसी सिस्टम
नेटवर्क या एप्लीकेशन की वनेबिलिटीज को
एक्सप्लइट करता है। इन सिंपल वर्ड्स अटैक
वेक्टर्स आर स्पेसिफिक अवेन्यूस थ्रू
व्हिच एन अटैकर गेन अन ऑथराइज एक्सेस अचीव
मशियस ऑब्जेक्ट और कॉम्प्रोमाइज द
सिक्योरिटी ऑफ ए टारगेट एनवायरमेंट। अगर
हम सिंपल शब्दों में बात करें यह वो
स्पेसिफिक गलियां या वो स्पेसिफिक दरवाजे
या वो स्पेसिफिक रास्ते होते हैं जहां से
एक अटैकर आपके एनवायरमेंट में अनऑथराइज्ड
एंट्री लेता है और अनऑथोराइज्ड
ऑब्जेक्टिव परफॉर्म करता है अचीव करता है
या आपका जो टारगेट एनवायरमेंट है उन
रास्तों से क्या करता है को पूरी तरह से
कंप्रोमाइज कर लेता है तो इसलिए यह वो
गलियां वो रास्ते या वह दरवाजे जहां से एक
अटैकर बिना परमिशन के अन ऑथराइज तरीके से
आपके घर तक पहुंच सकता है। वह क्या कहलाता
है? आपका अटैक वेक्टर्स। बिल्कुल ही
लेममेन भाषा में। पेनिट्रेशन टेस्ट
सिमुलेट दी अटैक वेक्टर्स टू आइडेंटिफाई
एंड एक्सेस वनेबिलिटीज मेजर्स द
इफेक्टिवनेस ऑफ सिक्योरिटी कंट्रोल्स एंड
प्रोवाइड रिकमेंडेशन फॉर इंप्रूविंग एंड
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन ऑफ वाइल सिक्योरिटी प्रोसेस।
एज एज ए पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर्स हम इन्हीं
अटैक वेक्टर्स को सिमुलेट करते हैं ताकि
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन को बता सकें कि उनके डिफेंस
में कहां-कहां लूप होल्स है या कहां-कहां
से एक अटैकर्स या एक बैड एक्टस एंटर कर
सकता है या वह कौन सी गलियां वो कौन से
रास्ते हैं जहां से कोई एक चोर आ सकता है
और आपके सिस्टम के अंदर एंट्री कर सकता है
या आपके घर में चोरी कर सकता है। वी आर
परफॉर्मिंग लाइक एंड डिटेक्टिव।
नाउ चलो फिर बात करते हैं अब क्लाइंट साइड
अटैक वेक्टर्स की। अब हम बात करते हैं
क्लाइंट साइड अटैक वेक्टर्स की। अभी हमारे
पास क्या है कि जो अटैक वेक्टर्स होते हैं
उसकी काफी ब्रॉड रेंज होती है। उनमें से
हम कुछ को डिस्कस करने वाले हैं। हियर आर
सम ऑफ द मोस्ट कॉमन एंड इफेक्टिव क्लाइंट
साइड अटैक वेक्टर्स यूज्ड फॉर इनिशियल
एक्सेस बाय अटैकर्स और पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टर्स। मतलब वैसे तो हमारे पास क्लाइंट
साइड अटैक वेक्टर बहुत सारे होते हैं
इनमें से लेकिन जो सबसे ज्यादा कॉमन और जो
सबसे ज्यादा इफेक्टिव क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स
होते हैं जो इफेक्टिव क्लाइंट साइड अटैक
वेक्टर्स होते हैं इनिशियल एक्सेस के लिए
उनके बारे में अभी हम डिस्कस करने वाले
हैं। उनमें से सबसे पहला है आपका सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग।
अब सोशल इंजीनियरिंग पूरी तरह से इंसानी
दिमाग और उसकी साइकोलॉजी को मैनपुलेट करने
का गेम है। आई एम रिपीटिंग अगेन जो सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग है वो पूरी तरह से किसी भी
इंसानी दिमाग या उसकी साइकोलॉजी को
मैनपुलेट करने का पूरा गेम है। वही अगर
कोई भी अटैकर या एथिकल हैकर कोई भी
पेंटेस्टर अगर किसी भी इंसानी दिमाग की को
पढ़ सकता है, समझ सकता है या उसकी
साइकोलॉजी को मैनपुलेट कर सकता है तो वो
सबसे बेस्ट सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक परफॉर्म
कर सकता है। और इस सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक
के अंदर कुछ मेजर सबक्टर्स आते हैं।
जिनमें से सबसे पहले है आपका फेसिंग ईमेल।
जिनमें से सबसे पहले आपका क्या है? फेसिंग
ईमेल्स। फेसिंग ईमेल में रिसेप्टिव ईमेल्स
विद मिलिशियस अटैचमेंट्स और लिंक्स टू
ट्रिक यूज़र्स इनू क्लिकिंग और डाउनलोडिंग
मालवेयर।
मतलब सबसे कॉमन अटैक वेक्टर में से एक
अटैक वेक्टर है आपका फेसिंग ईमेल्स।
जिसमें क्या जिसके अंदर आते हैं आपकी
डिसेप्टिव ईमेल्स। डिसेप्टिव मतलब फेक और
डुप्लीकेट ईमेल्स। ईमेल्स विद मिलिशियस
अटैचमेंट। हम क्या करते हैं कि हम किसी भी
टारगेट के पास डिसेप्टिव इमेज भेजते हैं
ताकि वो टारगेट उन पर क्लिक करें और जैसे
वह क्लिक करें हमारा काम हो जाए। सेकंड है
सोशल मीडिया इंजीनियरिंग। क्रिएटिंग फेक
प्रोफाइल्स टू कनेक्ट विद यूज़र्स एंड
डिसीव्यू देम इनू क्लिकिंग ऑन मिलसियस
लिंक्स और डाउनलोडिंग इनफेक्टेड कंटेंट।
अब मैं आपको समझा रहा हूं कि कौन-कौन से
अटैक वेक्टर है। कौन-कौन से तरीके हैं
जिनसे आप क्या कर सकते हो? क्लाइंट साइड
अटैक परफॉर्म कर सकते हो। ठीक है? तो सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग में फेसिंग ईमेल हो गया। फेस
दूसरा सब फैक्टर कौन सा है आपका? सोशल
मीडिया इंजीनियरिंग। जिसमें आप क्या करते
हो? एक फेक प्रोफेशनल प्रोफाइल बनाते हो।
किसके ऊपर? किसी भी Lindin के ऊपर या
Twitter के ऊपर। और फिर क्या करता है?
अटैकर टारगेट एंप्लॉय से दोस्ती
दोस्ती या फॉर्मल रिलेशनशिप बिल्ड करता है
या इस्टैब्लिश करता है और उसके बाद उसका
ट्रस्ट जीतता है और ट्रस्ट जीतने के बाद
क्या करता है उनको कोई मिलीशियस लिंक सेंड
करता है और जब आप भैया किसी पर विश्वास
करते हो तब विश्वासघात भी हो सकता है तो
यह वही है विश्वासघात करना उसके साथ जिसके
जिसके साथ आपने ट्रस्ट इस्टैब्लिश किया है
तो विश्वासघात है आपका सोशल मीडिया
इंजीनियरिंग िंग का एक एग्जांपल। नेक्स्ट
आपका प्री टेक्स्टिंग, बेटिंग एंड
टेलगेटिंग। वेरियस टैिक यूज्ड टू मैनपुलेट
यूज़र्स इनू
डेविलंग सेंसिटिव इनेशन और परफॉर्मिंग
एक्शन दैट फैसिलेट द अटैक। आई होप यह आपको
समझ में नहीं आया होगा। तो मैं बताता हूं
प्री टेक्स्टिंग क्या होता है। प्री
टेक्स्टिंग क्या होता है कि एक फेक पर
लगभग सच लगने वाली कहानी तैयार करना या
लगभग या सच लगने वाली कहानी को बनाना। फॉर
एग्जांपल आप किसी भी एक ऑर्गेनाइजेशन को
टारगेट कर रहे हो और आपको पता है कि वो
ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस के जो आईटी उसके अंदर काम
करने के लिए आईटी स्टाफ थर्ड पार्टी है तो
आप क्या करते हो उस ऑर्गेनाइजेशन को आईटी
स्टाफ बनकर कॉल करते हो और एंप्लई को
कन्वेंस करने की कोशिश करते हो कि सर या
मैडम या जो भी व्हाटएवर वर्ड यू वांट टू
यूज़ टू कन्वेंस द एंप्लॉय कि आपके आपके
सिस्टम आउटडेटेड हैं, अनपेस्ड हैं। आप
उनको अपग्रेड करना है तो प्लीज उनको
अपग्रेड करने के लिए आप यह फाइल रन करिए।
तो यह आपका क्या है? आपका एक प्री
टेक्स्टिंग है। आप क्या कर रहे हो? किसी
भी एंप्लई को कन्विंस कर रहे हो, मना रहे
हो।
लेकिन उससे पहले आपने क्या किया? एक कहानी
बनाई। क्या बन गए आप? उन्हीं के एक आईटी
स्टाफ मेंबर बन गए जो आप हो नहीं। नेक्स्ट
आता है बैटिंग। बैटिंग क्या होता है कि
इंसान को लालच या क्यूरोसिटी का
सॉरी इंसान के लालच या क्यूरोसिटी को
टारगेट करना। किसके अंदर आता है? आपका
वेटिंग। लालच मतलब ग्रिड। या क्यूरोसिटी
मतलब आप उत्सुकता। मतलब कि उसको फॉर
एग्जांपल आपने क्या किया? उसको फ्री
सॉफ्टवेयर ऑफर कर दिए। ऑब्वियसली कोई चीज
आपको फ्री मिलेगी तो आप तो आप में तो लालच
तो आएगा ही आएगा। ने बोला कि यह इतनी
महंगी चीज थी। यह यहां पर फ्री मिल रही
है। दैट इज द पार्ट ऑफ वेटिंग। या फिर
डिस्काउंट कूपन प्रोवाइड कर दिए। कोई चीज
5000 की थी और आपको ₹1000 में मिल रही।
₹4000 डिस्काउंट कूपन लालच आ गया।
क्यूसिटी भी बढ़ गई। उसके अलावा यार
किसी ऐसी इंफॉर्मेशन का लालच देकर उससे
कुछ डाउनलोड करवा लिया। कोई ऐसी
इंफॉर्मेशन है जो जिसमें उसको लगा यार कि
यह इंफॉर्मेशन मेरे पास किसी ने नहीं दी।
तो यह सामने वाला कितना मेरे को ट्रस्ट
करता है। मतलब उसकोेंस दे दिया है। तो तब
भी क्या है? और उससे कोई फाइल डाउनलोड
करवा ली। दैट इज आल्सो ए पार्ट ऑफ वेटिंग।
नाउ कम थर्ड आता है आपका टेल गेटिंग। टेल
गेटिंग क्या होता है? टेल गेटिंग एक
फिजिकल सोशल इंजीनियरिंग अटैक है। मैं
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग पढ़ाऊंगा। तो उनमें बहुत
इन टर्म्स को थोड़ा डीप में पढ़ेंगे कि ये
टर्म्स होती क्या है? सोशल इंजीनियरिंग के
टाइप्स कितने होते हैं? कंपोनेंट्स क्या
होते हैं? व्हाटएवर व्हाटएवर सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग कैसे की जाती है? ये सारी चीज
हम बात करने वाले हैं। जल्दी हम स्टार्ट
कर देंगे सोशल इंजीनियरिंग को भी। वो
ज्यादा दूर नहीं है। तो टेल गेटिंग क्या
होता है? एक आपका फिजिकल सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
अटैक है। उसमें क्या करता है कि फॉर
एग्जांपल अगर आपने क्या किया? टारगेट
कंपनी के किसी एंप्लई से फॉर्मल या
इनफॉर्मल दोस्ती कर ली। अब कोई दोस्ती कोई
किसी भी टाइप की हो सकती है। आपने वो कर
ली। अब जब आपकी दोस्ती गहरी है तो जो आपका
टारगेट है वह आपको अपनी कंपनी में इनवाइट
कर रहा है। ठीक है? और जब टारगेट अपनी
कंपनी में इनवाइट कर रहा है आपको विजिट के
लिए तो आप जाओगे और जैसे ही आप टारगेट से
मिलने के लिए जाते हो उसकी कंपनी में
टारगेट क्या करता है ऑफिस बिल्डिंग का जो
भी सिक्योर एरिया है जो भी सिक्योर डोर है
उसमें क्या करता है टारगेट अपना विजिटिंग
पास यूज़ करेगा मतलब विजिटिंग कार्ड होगा
या उसका एक्सेस कार्ड स्वाइप करेगा अब
एक्सेस कार्ड तो स्वाइप किया आपका टारगेट
ने बट आप उनके दोस्त थे अब जैसे आप उनके
दोस्त थे आप उनके पीछे पीछे क्या करोगे
बिना कार्ड के उसके ऑफिस के अंदर एंट्री
ले लोगे या उसके नेटवर्क में घुस जाओगे
दैट इज ए पार्ट ऑफ टेलगेटिंग
बस इतना ही तो करना है। तो आई होप क्लियर
है यह अटैक वेक्टर क्लियर है आपको सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग का अटैक वेक्टर क्लियर है
यह फर्स्ट सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का अटैक
वेक्टर क्लियर है सबको एवरीवन
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का अटैक वेक्टर क्लियर
है एवरीवन
मजा आया क्लास में मुझे लगता है कि
प्रीवियस क्लास से कम मुझे लगता है थोड़ा
सा आपको बोरिंग लग रहा है दैट्स व्हाई
क्लास मैं ज्यादा लंबी नहीं खींचूंगा
थोड़ा सा मजा आ रहा है चीजों को या थोड़े
से बोर हो गए। प्लीज मुझे बता दीजिए कि
देखो आपका जो रिव्यू है मेरे लिए बहुत
मैटर करता है। हो सकता है कि आपको इसके
क्लास नंबर 60 में बहुत ज्यादा मजा आया
हो। 61 में हो सकता है कि मेरा पैटर्न बदल
गया हो। पढ़ाने का तरीका बदल गया हो। कुछ
और हो जो आपको फील हो रहा है। प्लीज टेल
मी। 100% मैं इंप्लीमेंट करूंगा और
नेक्स्ट क्लास में वह आपको देखने को
मिलेगा।
प्लीज टेल मी।
तो चलिए फिर नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट अटैक वेक्टर
होता है आपका मलेशियस डॉक्यूमेंट या
पेसर्स।
देखो यार सोशल इंजीनियरिंग नहीं है। इतना
प्रैक्टिकल नहीं दिखा सकते। बट आई विल
ट्राई कि कुछ प्रैक्टिकल रहे जैसे कि आप
वो इंफॉर्मेशन कैसे गैदर हो सकती है। आई
विल ट्राई कि मैं आपको दिखा दूं मेरे
सिस्टम पे। बट प्रॉब्लम क्या है कि सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग आज मैं इस पे दिखा दूंगा। मैं
प्रैक्टिकली पूरा दिखा दूंगा।
अगले दिन ही कोई ना कोई इस पे कंटेंट राइट
मार देगा। प्रॉब्लम क्या है कि बहुत लोग
हैं आंटी जिसमें
जो चीजें हैं ना वह
बहुत खतरनाक वाली होती हैं। तो वो अगर मैं
परफॉर्म करके दिखाऊंगा ना तो कोई भी मे
अगेंस्ट हो सकता है। बट उसका भी कुछ सशन
ढूंढने की कोशिश करता हूं कि आपको कोई ऐसा
प्रैक्टिकल दिखाया जाए। कुछ ऐसा
रियलिस्टिक आपको दिखाया जाए जो मे बी
आपको थोड़ा सा लगे कि हां प्रैक्टिकल ऐसे
हो सकता है। आई विल ट्राई।
ओके तो आई विल ट्राई अमन पटेल
यह सब होता है मैं बताऊंगा देखो पहले नहीं
है जस्ट फॉलो लेक्चर्स उसमें जो जो मैं
डिस्कस कर रहा हूं प्लीज ध्यान से सुनो
नहीं समझ में आता प्लीज आस्क मी
ओके तो नेक्स्ट आपका मलेशियस डॉक्यूमेंट
एंड पे्स अब जब एक बार आपने सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग से
से अपना टारगेट तैयार कर लिया। यह आपका जो
टारगेट है वह तैयार हो गया। सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग से। अब कोई भी टेक्निक आपने
यूज़ की चाहे आपने फिशिंग ईमेल भेजी हो,
आपने सोशल मीडिया इंजीनियरिंग की हो, प्री
टेक्स्टिंग की हो, बैटिंग की हो, टेल
गेटिंग की हो, कुछ भी किया हो, आपने अपने
टारगेट को तैयार कर लिया। तब बारी आती है
आपके टेक्निकल एग्जीक्यूशन की। और
टेक्निकल एग्जीक्यूशन में क्या होता है
आपका? क्राफ्टेड डॉक्यूमेंट्स। फॉर
एग्जांपल Microsoft Office फाइल्स पीडीएफ
विद एंबेडेड मैकज़ स्क्रिप्ट्स और
एक्सप्लइड दैट एग्जीक्यूट मलशियस कोड अपॉन
ओपनिंग दैट एग्जीक्यूट मलेशियस कोड अपॉन
ओपनिंग मतलब
इसमें हमने क्या किया? हम ज्यादातर क्या
करते हैं? Microsoft Office फाइल या
पीडीएफ का यूज़ करते हैं। क्योंकि सबसे
ज्यादा क्या होती है? किसी भी कंपनी में
अब कोई भी नॉर्मल एंप्लई सबसे ज्यादा किस
चीज को डील करता है? आप ही बताइए। या तो
Microsoft Office डील करता है या पीडीएफ
फाइल के साथ डील करता है। तो हम इसी को
अपना क्या करते हैं? हथियार बनाते हैं।
सबसे ज्यादा हम इसी को टारगेट करते हैं
Microsoft Office फाइल को या पीडीएफ को।
और इनके अंदर हमने क्या किया? कस्टम
वीवीएम मैक्रोज़ या एंबेड स्क्रिप्ट्स हो
गई या नॉन फ्लोज़ को क्या कर दिया हमने?
उसके एक्सप्लइट छुपा देते हैं। और जैसे ही
वह फाइल ओपन होती है तो वह एग्जीक्यूट हो
जाते हैं। तो मतलब यह है कि मिलिश
डॉक्यूमेंट से इस अटैक वेक्टर का मतलब यह
है कि हम क्या करते हैं? एक डॉक्यूमेंट
करेक्ट करते हैं। हमें पता है कि सामने
वाले के सिस्टम पर कौन सा सॉफ्टवेयर रन कर
रहा है या कौन सा एडoब रीडर यूज़ कर रहा
है। उसका वर्जन क्या है और उसके अकॉर्डिंग
हम क्या करते हैं? एक फाइल रेडी करते हैं।
उस फाइल में कोई एक पेलोड
उसके अंदर पेलोड छुपाते हैं। और जैसे वो
फाइल ओपन होगी वो पेलोड एग्जीक्यूट हो
जाएगा। यह होता है आपका सेकंड क्लाइंट
साइड अटैक फैक्टर्स। नेक्स्ट आता है आपका
वेब एंड ब्राउज़र बेस्ड एक्टर। वेब एंड
ब्राउज़र बेस्ड अटैक। अब यहां इसमें क्या
होता है? यहां पर अब यहां यूजर को किसी भी
फाइल को डाउनलोड करने की जरूरत नहीं होती।
वेब और ब्राउज़र बेस्ड अटैकर में यूजर को
किसी भी फाइल को डाउनलोड करने की जरूरत
नहीं होती। बस उसको एक गलत वेबसाइट को
विजिट करना विजिट करना पड़ता है या
उससे कोई एक बैड वेबसाइट विजिट करवानी
होती है। बस इतना ही करवाना होता है वेब
और ब्राउज़र बेस्ड अटैक वेक्टर के अंदर और
आपका काम हो जाएगा। नहीं समझ में मैं
रिपीट करता हूं कि वेब और ब्राउज़र बेस्ड
अटैक वेक्टर के अंदर यूजर को कोई भी फाइल,
कोई भी ईमेल डाउनलोड करने की जरूरत नहीं
होती। उसको जस्ट बस क्या करना होता है?
कोई भी एक बैड वेबसाइट, कोई भी एक
कॉम्प्रोमाइज वेबसाइट या कोई भी एक गलत
वेबसाइट है उसको विजिट करना ही काफी होता
है। फॉर एग्जांपल जैसे इसका पहला जो अटैक
वेक्टर कौन सा होगा? सब अटैक वेक्टर
ड्राइव बाय डाउनलोड्स। ड्राइव बाय
डाउनलोड्स क्या होता है? होस्टिंग मिलस
कंटेंट और एक्सप्लइट किट ऑन
कॉम्प्रोमाइज्ड और मिलसियस वेबसाइट टू
ऑटोमेटिकली डाउनलोड एंड एग्जीक्यूट
मालवेयर व्हेन यूजर विजिट द साइट। व्हेन
यूजर विजिट द साइट। मतलब अटैकर क्या करता
है? किसी भी कॉम्प्रोमाइज या मिलिशियस
वेबसाइट पर एक एक्सप्लइट किट होस्ट कर
देता है और जैसे ही यूजर उस साइट को विजिट
करता है तो उसके सिस्टम में बैकग्राउंड
में बिना उसकी परमिशन के मालवेयर
ऑटोमेटिकली डाउनलोड या एग्जीक्यूट हो जाता
है। मालवेयर ऑटोमेटिकली डाउनलोड या
एग्जीक्यूट हो जाता है। दैट दैट टाइप ऑफ
अटैक इज नोन एज ड्राइव बाय डाउनलोड
अटैक्स। नाउ नेक्स्ट कम टू आवर वाटरिंग
होल अटैक्स। यह भी इसका सब अटैक वेक्टर
आता है। वाटरिंग होल अटैक्स क्या होता है
कि कंप्रोमाइज वेबसाइट फ्रीक्वेंटेड बाय द
टारगेट ऑडियंस एंड इंजेक्टिंग मिलिशियस
कोड और लिंक्स टू इनफेक्टेड विजिटर्स
सिस्टम्स। अब नहीं समझ में आया होगा कि यह
सबसे इंटरेस्टिंग अटैक होता है। कैसे?
अटैकर्स पूरे इंटरनेट पर अटैक नहीं करता।
वह सिर्फ टारगेटेड ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के
एमंप्लाइज की जो भी हैबिट्स हैं उनको
मॉनिटर करता है। इसमें क्या करता है जो
अटैकर है जो आपके टारगेट ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
उसके जो भी एंप्लाइजज़ हैं उनकी जो भी
हैबिट्स हैं उनको मॉनिटर करता है। जैसे
फॉर एग्जांपल कि जो कॉर्पोरेट एंप्लाइजज़
हैं वो लंच टाइम में किसी लोकल फूड
डिलीवरी साइट साइट का यूज करते हैं फूड
ऑर्डर करने के लिए। या क्या करते हैं वो
इंडस्ट्री की कोई इंडस्ट्री न्यूज़ फॉर्म
है उस पे सबसे ज्यादा विजिट करते हैं।
सबसे ज्यादा उस पे जाते हैं। तो क्या
अटैकर क्या करेगा? उन्हीं स्पेसिफिक
वेबसाइट को कंप्रोमाइज करेगा।
कॉम्प्रोमाइज करके उनके ऊपर मिलेशियस कोड
इंजेक्ट कर देगा। अब क्या होगा? जैसे ही
उस कॉरपोरेशन के एंप्लई या उस कॉर्पोरेट
के एंप्लई उस साइट पर विजिट करेंगे जो
किसने की की अटैकर ने इनफेक्टेड की है तो
वह एंप्लई भी इनफेक्टेड हो जाएंगे। वाटर
होलिंग अटैक का मतलब क्या हुआ? अटैकर ने
क्या किया? अभी इंटरनेट पे कुछ नहीं करना।
उसे बस क्या करना है? जो भी एंप्लई कंपनी
के अंदर काम कर रहे हैं उनके बिहेवियर को
मॉनिटर करना है कि भैया किस टाइम पे वो
क्या-क्या करते हैं। तो जैसे कि हमें पता
चला कि उस वो एंप्लॉय दोपहर को एक तो फूड
डिलीवरी एप्लीकेशन यूज़ करते हैं या कोई
न्यूज़ देखने के लिए इस वेबसाइट को यूज़
करते हैं। मतलब इन दो वेबसाइट को वो
फ्रीक्वेंटली यूज़ करते हैं। तो अटैकर ने
क्या किया? इन्हीं दोनों में से दोनों
वेबसाइट को कॉम्प्रोमाइज किया। उनके अपने
अंडर उसके अंदर कोई मिलसियस कोड
एग्जीक्यूट कर दिया। रख दिया। अब जैसे ही
क्या करेगा वो एंप्लई उस वेबसाइट पर
फ्रीक्वेंटली जाएगा और जैसे फ्रीक्वेंटली
जाएगा वो उसका शिकार हो जाएगा। दैट इज
कॉल्ड वाटर होल अटैक्स। दैट इज वॉल वाटर
होल अटैक।
समझ में आ गया? दैट इज कॉल्ड वाटर होल
अटैक।
अमन पटेल हो सकता है सारी चीजें पॉसिबल
है। बट इट इज अ वेरी वेरी बेसिक
इंटरमीडिएट कोर्स जिसमें चीजें अभी हम
पढ़ा नहीं रहे हैं। तो यह मैं पढ़ाने वाला
भी नहीं हूं। बट
देखते हैं कभी पढ़ाएंगे तो नहीं पढ़ाएंगे।
अदरवाइज आपको खुद से ही रिसर्च करनी
पड़ेगी। यू कैन मेक इट फूड फुल्ली
अनडिटक्टेबल
पे लोड बना सकते हो। नो प्रॉब्लम। वि द
हेल्प ऑफ ए
ऑफ स्केटिंग। जितना ज्यादा फ्रस्टेट कर
सकते हो उसके सिग्नेचर को बदल बदल के।
तो आई होप वाटर होलिंग अटैक क्लियर है।
वाटर होलिंग क्लियर है।
ओके। तो नेक्स्ट
इसी के वेब एंड ब्राउज़र बेस अटैक वेक्टर
के अंदर आते हैं आपके ब्राउज़र
एक्सप्लइटेशन और एक्सप्लइट किड्स। ब्राउज़र
एक्सप्लइटेशन की बात करते हैं।
एक्सप्लइटिंग वनेबिलिटीज इन वेब ब्राउज़र्स
और देयर कंपोनेंट टू एग्जीक्यूट
आर्बिट्रेरी कोड और परफॉर्म एक्शनंस ऑन द
विक्टिम सिस्टम्स। एक्सप्लइट किट्स की बात
करें यूजिंग ऑटोमेटेड किट्स टू टारगेट
वनेबिलिटीज इन वेब ब्राउज़र्स प्लगिंस और
अदर क्लाइंट साइड सॉफ्टवेयर स्ट्रीम
लाइनिंग द प्रोसेस ऑफ डिलीवरिंग एंड
एग्जीक्यूटिंग मिलस मतलब हम बात करते हैं
ब्राउज़र एक्सप्लइटेशन और एक्सप्लइट किट
की जैसे कि आपका क्रोम ब्राउज़र हो गया
आपका Firefox हो गया आपका एज ब्राउज़र हो
गया या उनके जो एक्सटेंशनंस होंगे जो
प्लगइंस होंगे उनके अंदर जो भी अनपैच्ड
वनेबिलिटीज है उनको डायरेक्टली
कॉम्प्रोमाइज करना डायरेक्टली लिए टारगेट
करना ताकि जो विक्टिम का सिस्टम है
विक्टिम मतलब आपका जो टारगेट सिस्टम है जो
एंप्लई है उसके सिस्टम पे आप क्या कर सको
रिमोट कोड एग्जीक्यूशन ले सको या रिमोट
कोड एग्जीक्यूशन परफॉर्म कर सको दैट इज
आल्सो ए पार्ट ऑफ क्लाइंट साइड अटैक
वेक्टर्स कम्स अंडर वेब एंड ब्राउज़र बेस्ड
वेक्टर्स
क्लियर
ये चीज क्लियर है बताइए
दिस इज अ आवर लास्ट एंड आज का लास्ट टॉपिक
है नॉट लीस्ट ठीक है लास्ट टॉपिक है तो
चलिए फिर नेक्स्ट आपका है हार्डवेयर
वेक्टर्स। तो यूएसबी बेस्ड अटैक वेक्टर्स
डिस्ट्रीब्यूटिंग मालवेयर इनफेक्टेड
यूएसबी ड्राइव्स और डिवाइसेस इन पब्लिक
स्पेसेस और टारगेटेड एनवायरमेंट टू
ऑटोमेटिकली एग्जीक्यूट मालवेयर व्हेन
यूज़र्स प्लग देम इनू देयर कंप्यूटरटर्स।
अब इसमें क्या करता है अटैकर कि कोई भी
मिलीसियस या इनफेक्टेड यूएसबी ड्राइव को
कंपनी के या तो पार्किंग लॉट में या फिर
कैफेट एरिया में या आसपास के ऐसे किसी
पब्लिक स्पेस में जहां पर एंप्लई कंपनी के
एम्प्लाइज का फ्रीक्वेंटली आना जाना है
वहां पर क्या कर देगा इन यूएसबी ड्राइव्स
को ड्रॉप कर देगा और जब कोई भी एंप्लई
क्यूरसिटी में आकर उस यूएसबी को अपने
कॉर्पोरेट लैपटॉप में लगाएगा तो वह पेलोड
एग्जीक्यूट हो जाएगा तो यह भी एक आपका
क्या है अटैक फैक्टर है जो आपने कभी भी
कहीं सुना होगा या देखा होगा कि कहीं पर
भी आपने सीडी ड्राइव या कोई यूएसबी ड्राइव
को कहीं पे छोड़ दिया और किसी ने
क्रियोसिटी में आके और सी ड्राइव पे कुछ
लिखा हुआ था। सो एंड सो क्रियोसिटी में
आके उसने प्लग इन किया। प्लग इन करते वो
एग्जीक्यूट हो गया। दैट इज़ ए वन टाइप ऑफ ए
क्लाइंट साइड अटैक वेक्टर्स।
सो क्लास नाउ यू हैव कंप्लीटेड योर
फंडामेंटल्स अंडरस्टैंडिंग ऑफ व्हाट
क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स आर। उनका एग्जीक्यूशन
मेथोलॉजी क्या है? और उनके कौन-कौन से
अटैक फैक्टर्स रियल वर्ल्ड में यूज होते
हैं। तो नाउ टेल मी
एनी क्वेश्चंस
अप टू दिस पॉइंट? किसी को कोई सवाल है इस
पॉइंट तक?
किसी का भी कोई भी सवाल है तो बताइए।
एनीवन हैव एनी क्वेश्चंस अप टू दिस पॉइंट?
जो भी कुछ अभी तक पढ़ाया है।
अमन आई डिड एक्चुअली में आपके सवाल पे आते
हैं। फिर रमन पूछ रहे हैं जस्ट ऐड फ्रॉम
माय साइट वेब टेक्स्ट इफ साइट इज कनेक्टेड
टू द टारगेट सर्वर
पहली बात तो आपने इफ लगाया मुश्किल है कोई
भी साइट डायरेक्टली आपके उससे कनेक्ट
इंटरनेट नेटवर्क से नहीं होती अगर साइट
आपकी टारगेट वेब सर्वर
वेब अटैक्स है अगर आपकी साइट कनेक्टेड टू
टारगेट सर्वर है तो वह आपका वेब एप्लीकेशन
अटैक्स के अंदर आएगा है वो वो एक्सटर्नल
अटैक्स का पार्ट है बट वो क्लाइंट साइड
अटैक्स में नहीं होगा।
वो वाईफाई हैकिंग इज अ सेपरेट पार्ट ऑफ
दैट इज अ पार्ट ऑफ ए एक्सटर्नल पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग बट नॉट द पार्ट ऑफ ए योवर
क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स। हां, लेकिन एक पार्ट
हो सकता है कि क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स में
आपने क्या किया? उनके पार्किंग लॉट में
बैठकर और एविल डेविन अटैक या वह टाइप के
कर सकते हो या
या आपका सवाल अमन पटेल अगर और कुछ है तो
प्लीज राइट डाउन इन मैसेज आई विल आंसर
टीम पिकिकाचू
तो एक काम करो आपको वैसे तो लाइव क्लासेस
कर लेनी चाहिए। आपके लिए बेनिफिट होगा
बिकॉज़ इट अ टोटली डिफरेंट सिनेरियो
क्योंकि बट आपकी क्या है? बेसिक्स बहुत
अच्छे से कवर होंगे इसमें क्योंकि यह भी
बिल्कुल न्यू टॉपिक है। बिल्कुल न्यू टाइप
से हमने स्टार्ट किया है। लेकिन ये
डिपेंडेंट है। इसकी प्रीरिक्विजिट यह है
कि आपको पहले की चीजें आनी चाहिए। क्योंकि
जब आपको आईडिया मिल जाएगा टैक्स का लेकिन
होंगे कैसे वो पहले मैं सिखा चुका हूं। तो
वह आपको डेफिनेटली करने चाहिए।
और कोई कुछ पूछना चाहता है?
किसी को मेरे पढ़ाने के तरीकों को बदलवाना
है या उसके रिलेटेड कोई सवाल है, कोई
कंप्लेन है तो वह भी मुझसे आप पूछ सकते हो
या मुझे थोड़ा सा कुछ और इंप्रूवमेंट करना
चाहिए वह भी मुझसे बता सकते हो। आप कोई
सजेशन आपकी सलाह सर आप ऐसा कर सकते हो तो
आई विल डेफिनेटली इंप्रूव मसेल्फ
आपके लिए
बिल्कुल कर सकते हो फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल आपको यह
पता होना चाहिए कि
प्रोटेक्शंस क्या-क्या लगे हुए हैं।
प्रोटेक्शन में क्या-क्या लगे हुए हैं?
ठीक है? उसके बाद जो वर्जनंस यूज़ हो रहे
हैं अंदर क्या वो आउटडेटेड है या लेटेस्ट
हैं।
ओके? यह सारी चीजें क्योंकि पता चला कि आप
क्योंकि आपको क्या करना करना जब पेलोड
बनाना होगा, जब पेलोड क्राफ्ट करना होगा
तो उस उस केस में आपको क्या करना है कि
आपको वही चीज यूज़ करनी पड़ेगी ना जो उस पे
चल सकती है। आप ऐसा पेलोड यूज़ किया वो
आउटडेटेड वर्जन वाला है लेकिन वो पैज्ड
वर्जन होगा तो वैसे पेलोड काम नहीं करेगा
और कोई फायरवेल एक्टिवेट हो जाए या कोई
इवेंट एक्टिवेट हो जाए ये सारी चीज़ लेकिन
डेफिनेटली हो सकता है।
हो सकता है अमन पटेल पॉसिबल है। बट अगर
ऐसा कुछ करने की सोच रहे हो पहली बात फ़
माय साइड अह इट्स ए हंबल रिक्वेस्ट विदाउट
रिटन अथॉरिटी जब तक आपके पास रिटन में कोई
अथॉरिटी नहीं हो प्लीज डोंट डू नॉट
परफॉर्म एनी क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स बिकॉज़
इसमें कोई बचाएगा ही नहीं।
ओके रियल वर्क थ्रू चाहिए पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग और वेब एप्लीकेशन टेस्टिंग
रवि मोरे नाउ वी आर कवरिंग एक्सटर्नल
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग और जब एक्सटर्नल
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग की बात आ गई तो उसका
पार्ट तो यह भी है।
इट इज डेफिनेटली इट इज अ रियल रियल वर्ल्ड
हैकिंग 100%
आप कोई भी अटैक उठा के देखिए ज्यादातर कोई
भी साइबर क्राइम उठा के देखिए सब में सबसे
ज्यादा सोशल इंजीनियरिंग यूज़ होती है।
सबसे ज्यादा सोशल इंजीनियरिंग यूज़ होती
है। कितने भी साइबर क्राइम देखना सब में
यही है।
सामने वाले पे क्लिक क्लिंक करवाना हो
करवाना है। सारी चीजें हैं। कभी देखा है
कि कोई ऐसा अटैक रहा हो जिसमें पूरी तरह
उसने जीरो डे अलग चीज है। कोई ऐसा चीज कि
उसने बिल्कुल सामने वाले पे बिना क्लिक
करवाए कुछ करवाया हो। बहुत रेयर अटैक्स
होते हैं। ज्यादातर में सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
यूज़ करते ही करते हैं। क्योंकि यह सबसे
आसान तरीका है। किसी को भी कन्विंस करके
अटैक करना और रेदर देन आपको 6 महीने, 3
महीने उस पे काम करना, उसके अंदर वो
ढूंढना, उसके बाद फिर आगे मूवमेंट करना।
अब आपके पास सीधा एक्सेस मिल रहा है उस
सिस्टम के अंदर। तब आपके लिए तो फिर पोस्ट
एक्सप्ल करना इजी है रेदर देन कि इनिशियल
एक्सेस लिया उसके बाद वह एक्सेस कैसा मिला
यू डोंट नो यह सारी चीजें बहुत ज्यादा
टाइम कंज्यूमिंग है ना और उस टाइम को कम
करने के लिए क्लाइंट साइड अटैक इज द बेस्ट
अटैक क्योंकि वही है कि कोई भी
ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस
अपने एम्प्लाइज को इतना ट्रेंड कर ही नहीं
सकती सारे के सारे एम्प्लाइज को ट्रेंड हो
ही नहीं सकते
अच्छी अच्छी बात है।
अच्छी बात है अमन पटेल। तो किसी कोई सवाल
मुझसे पूछना चाहता है तो ठीक है। अदरवाइज
हम हां फॉर योर काइंड इन कल भी आपकी क्लास
होगी।
रेडी हो कल की क्लास के लिए भी? जैसे
मैंने आपको प्रॉमिस किया था। सैटरडे और
संडे हम दोनों दिन मिलेंगे। दोनों दिन हम
क्लास करेंगे। रेडी हो? कल की क्लास के
लिए भी एवरीवन
रेडी हो एवरीवन? कंटिन्यू करेंगे यहां से।
कल आपको थोड़ा सा और रियलिस्टिक सिनेरियो
बताऊंगा मैं आपको। एक और रियलिस्टिक
सिनेरियो हम डिस्कस करने वाले हैं।
नो
अमन आपने क्या किया? दो चीज मिक्स कर दी।
थोड़ा सा पार्ट यूज किया बट थोड़ा सा पार्ट
नहीं यूज किया। प्योर क्लाइंट से अटैक्स
नहीं बोल सकते।
ओके तो और कोई क्यूरी
या कोई और डिमांड हो कि सर इस चीज पर भी
वीडियो आनी चाहिए। इस चीज को भी कवर किया
जाना चाहिए।
कोई मुझसे कुछ डिमांड हो कि सर यह चीज भी
कवर होनी चाहिए।
ऐसा कुछ है किसी का?
अदरवाइज फिर हम सेशन को एंड करते हैं। फिर
है किसी के कुछ एनीवन?
नो
बताइए बताइए जल्दी से
यस या नो
चलिए फिर सेशन को एंड करते हैं।
या आई एम एग्री विद यू रवि मोरे बिकॉज़
ट्यूटोरियल्स में रियल पैंथस्टिंग की थोड़ी
सी झलक हो सकती है लेकिन वह नहीं आ सकता
क्योंकि यहां सब आप टैक्टिक्स ट्रिक्स बता
सकते हो बट वहां पे रियल चैलेंजेस बहुत
सारी चीजें अलग होती हैं।
चलिए फिर ओके बाय-ब एंड गुड नाइट एवरीवन।
सी यू फॉर टुमारो सेशन। कल भी हम सेम
क्लास नंबर 62 में मिलते हैं और सेम टॉपिक
को कंटिन्यू करते हैं। ओके गुड बाय एवरीवन
एंड सी यू फॉर टुमारो। गुड नाइट एवरीवन।
बाय बाय।